good morning members members of the
public officers and others present and
those watching online um apologies first
of all for the delay in starting we had
a couple of technical issues that we
just needed to resolve before starting
sydney
slightly alicia thank you
so
um my name is robert carmichael i am the
governance officer for this meeting and
i will be opening the meeting until we
elect a chair for this morning so i'll
run through the domestic arrangements
first
please ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons whilst
in the chamber and in the communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face
covering at all times unless you are
sitting down or or you are exempt from
doing so
and that you use the hand sanitizer and
wipes provided
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
and please do not interrupt other
speakers or hold separate conversations
whilst others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are
switched off or on silent
and finally we'll be using the e-voting
for this morning on the modern.gov app
so i've just run through the fire safety
part as well so when evacuating the
building please leave the building
immediately via the fire exits and make
your way to the assembly point on
ipswich town football ground training
pitch please follow the signs directing
you to the fire exits at each end of the
floor and do not enter the atrium or the
ground floor area or the walkways
if you are in the atrium at the time of
the alarm follow the size of the nearest
fire exit
use the stairs not the lifts and do not
re-enter the building until you are told
it is safe to do so
i would like to remind everyone present
that the meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you are if you make a representation
to the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council and to the possible use
of those images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
and i'll just go through the
introductions of the officers here and
the board members as well that are on
the agenda today so first of all we have
mr ian depray the planning lawyer and
legal advisor to this committee
mr paytman g
area planning manager
we have
alex scott case officer
we have philip isbell chief planning
officer
and we have the ward members listed but
i don't think they have arrived yet of
on the items today of penny orton except
sorry councillor otton councilman mellon
councillor hicks councillor morrison
councillor humphreys councillor
haddington councillor stringer and we'll
come and turn to council richardson
council turner with an update from the
chief planning officer
so first of all um members are the
election of the chair
so members are asked to note that should
the result of a vote be a draw there
will be no casting vote and vote will be
taken again until a chair is elected
so
on that point could i please ask for
nominations for a chair councillor
stringer i'd like to nominate councillor
dave muller
thank you councillor
could i have a second to please
counselor more boys i think you
thank you very much
are there any other nominations
no thank you members i will just put
that into the mongol vote
and then we will go to the vote on that
so members that's now been updated in
your modern.gov app and i will start the
vote
counselor david byrne can i please take
your vote verbally
four four thank you
thank you members all of votes have now
been received and that is unanimous vote
for councillor muller what i would
suggest is that we take a very short
break just so that councilman can move
up to the top table thank you
foreign
proposing this chair today so thank you
for that
i'd like to move to the agenda please do
we have any apologies for absence and
substitutions please
thank you chair we have apologies from
councillor guthrie and councillor
carsten
councillor byrne is substituted for
councillor guthrie and councillor mayor
substituting for caster carsten
thank you
right
to receive declarations of pecuniary and
non-cunery interest by members are there
any to declare
council stringer
thank you chair i have a non-pecuniary
interest in item seven c and d yeah i
i'm a director of a another mid-suffolk
supported arts venue uh i thought it's
only fair to declare that thank you very
much coach lemayo
yeah thank you um
7b i'm um a board member of suffolk
holdings i don't believe they're
involved in that particular thank you
and thank you hold on there's more sorry
apologies and a 7c and d i'm
not a member of
that particular organization but i
utilize it and frequent it on a very
regular basis
thank you very much okay the gold please
thank you chair um
for uh just for reasons of uh
transparency i don't subject officer
advice don't think it has any uh other
implications um that
7c and 7d
uh are in my county council division
thank you very much indeed
okay
um are there any declarations of
lobbying from members certainly i've
been lobbied
yes thank you i was certainly lobbied on
the application
regarding um
ethelington the one in horror mode
ethelington was anybody else
yes
yeah
same chair same yeah anybody any other
applications that anyone else was
no okay thank you
sorry councilman sorry
i think it's uh yeah i've been lobbied
on 7a although that's been called 7b and
8a thank you very much indeed for that
okay are there any declarations of
personal site visits
no
okay thank you very much i'll move on to
item six can we have confirmation of the
minutes of the meeting held on the 4th
of august
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes and could i have
a proposal and a second to police
counselor stringer please yeah i'd like
to propose they're an accurate record
thank you very much do i have a second
to please
occasionally warboys i think i saw your
hand got
sorry yeah came to the melon
thank you very much that's councillor
stringer proposed countless melon to
second okay
in that case what we'll do
i will now ask the government's officer
to conduct the electronic vote please
thank you
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress
on the modern.gov app counselor david
burns can i please take your vote
verbally
yes sir i wasn't present at that meeting
but
does that mean that i should have
staying
the general accordance is that if you're
not at a meeting that you possibly you
probably should abstain there's nothing
in law that prevents you from voting for
or against
okay well i will abstain thank you thank
you
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is three votes four
and five abstentions so that is carriage
okay thank you very much indeed um
do we have any notification or petitions
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme
none received
okay in that case i'd like to move on to
the schedule of planning applications
i believe the chief planning officer
would like to make a comment about item
7a
dc205894 the land south west of bayton
road thurston
thank you strisfelt
thank you chairman good morning members
um so the application uh at baton rouge
thurston uh as circulated by email
yesterday i would propose to
withdraw from this agenda and i'm not
intending to present information on it
we received a request yesterday from the
applicant they have taken stock of the
committee report and there are various
items in there including
changes to the
dormer arrangements parking arrangements
tree protection and planting which they
would like to take stock of
and to amend
before the application is decided now
members will be aware that this site is
the subject of a judicial review that
does not preclude the council from
hearing it
but i think the intention on the part of
the developer is to
achieve a permission which can be
delivered if they are successful in
defending
together with ourselves the uh the
judicial review claim that's been made
so leaving aside that and i don't wish
to talk about that in any detail as far
as the reserve matters application goes
there are various conditions recommended
which will require require further work
and the request has been put to us that
the app can be allowed opportunity to
amend uh the design and layout
arrangements
which we will consult upon in due course
and bring the application back in front
of committee in the circumstances chair
it will usually be the case that this
will be discussed and agreed with the
chairman of the committee but in the
absence of the chairman i have to bring
it here
and i would ask that uh this be proposed
and seconded by the meeting
so that
that can be a formal record of
the arrangements thank you chairman
could i have a proposal and a second to
defer item 7a on the agenda councillor
mayor as a proposer and a second please
counselor norris thank you very much can
we go to the electronic vote please no
thank you
yep
thank you members so if you go to the
model.gov app the vote will now be in
progress
councillor burn could at least take your
vote verbally
four
thank you
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is a unanimous vote
for thank you very much thank you robert
thank you
next i would like to move on to item 7b
which is
the dc20404921 east of hockey hill
weathering set come brockford suffolk
and i would now invite the case officer
alex scott to introduce the application
to the committee please over to you alex
thank you
thank you chairman um members as the
chairman's explained this is item 7b in
the agenda application reference dc
04921 land east of hockey hill in
weathering set
the application before you is an
application for outline planning
permission
with consideration of access layout and
scale all to be considered as part of
this application
matters of appearance and landscaping
are
reserved so we don't have details of
that at present
and the application is for the erection
of 14 dwellings including four
affordable dwellings
and construction of
a new access through the
hockey hill estate
we'll just move on to the presentation
this is the location of weathering set
within the district for the avoidance of
that
the approximate location of the site
within the parish so off hockey hill and
hockey hill estate
just
like that for you over here
this is a aerial view of the
the wider area
and
an aerial view of the the site
location
this is a constraints map of the site
and
surroundings and the key
constraints i think to note are that the
site lies within the settlement boundary
as described within the
existing
development plan
and the the village itself is
designated
within uh
call strategy policy cs1 as a secondary
village
just for your information there
and
other
notable constraints there are a couple
of listed buildings here at pax's house
and hill farmhouse fronting hockey hill
within the vicinity and this purple
hatched area at the top is uh the
village conservation area which is uh
further up to the north on uh on hockey
hill
another site is essentially divided into
two sections
the first section is an existing area of
garages
12 garages fronting the
hockey hill
estate and
the remainder of the site an existing
grassed pastural uh field i think you
could describe it um measuring
approximately 0.97 hectares so uh almost
a hectare
in scale
and there is a um also an area of uh
crossing um
also within the red line of this uh
um what is termed in agricultural access
but uh as we go through uh the
presentation
um it's become apparent that this uh
perhaps isn't uh used for such purposes
but
there'll be more information hopefully
as we go through
the discussion for you on that point in
particular
the proposed layout
now this is uh
for consideration this is not indicative
um this is this is part of the
application
uh
as is the uh the access
which will be through the area of the
existing garages
and it's proposed to replace the 12
existing garages with parking spaces
in these locations
for the existing dwellings on the hockey
hill estate now this has been uh
um recommended um
and
agreed as part of mid-suffolk estates so
this is what they would like to see and
this is what the applicant has provided
as as part of the layout
the
in terms of the the scale of the the
dwellings proposed the
application proposes
eight bungalows including the uh
these five dwellings here
which would be closest to the existing
dwellings fronting uh hockey hill
and the four affordable houses are
in uh this location here
just for reference
and we also have the uh
attenuation basin
surface water drainage
basin um as part of the layout and this
has been uh
looked at and approved in in principle
by the local lead flood authority at the
county council
other points to note um there is a power
line which runs through a portion of the
site
and this
area here is the uh
the easement uh required
away from that and uh just to note we
have no buildings directly beneath that
uh
that line
so it may indicate why the garages have
been set so far back in the site
and this is a breakdown of the proposed
housing mix
as you can see
we have a mix of uh
two and three bedroom dwellings only so
smaller dwellings
and
eight bungalows as i've mentioned
and the affordable dwellings highlighted
here by asterisks plots five six seven
and eight
and the scale is indicated here as well
as the
floor area
um
scale of course part of what
we will be considering today
onto some photographs for you
this is the existing
hockey hill estate and the existing
garage blocks proposed to be removed
and the area of the proposed access
and just a view from the other side
so garage block here
there
and this is looking through the area of
the existing heart standing fronting the
garages
through
where the agricultural track or what is
termed the agricultural track
and the field beyond and this is the
rear of the existing dwellings found in
hockey hill
that's looking
back
down that
tract
access towards the
[Music]
highway
and then the rear of the dwellings
across
and then just looking out the other way
across the site
into the countryside you'll note
existing field boundary untreated
present
this is uh on the
main hockey hill highway and this is
where the estate road emerges onto that
there is a bus stop
in this location
close to the site
and this is where that track
we saw earlier emerges onto the uh onto
the highway
and then just looking back down
the highway towards the estate
access where that emerges onto the
highway
and then the frontage of the existing
dwellings
along hockey hill
and there you might be able to make at
pax's house the list of building thatch
cottage
over there in the distance
so that concludes the presentation i
said out in your papers officer
recommendation is for approval subject
to conditions thank you very much thank
you very much
i now open up the floor to questions
from members please do any members have
any questions for alex council stringer
please yep thank you chair uh
and do we have i've looked through the
papers i can't find it do we have a
response to the heritage officer
about moving the
pylons and electric lines closer to the
listed building
no i don't believe they covered that
point specifically in their response
hey
count to the melon please
thank you chad um
you mentioned earlier about the
agricultural track possibly not being in
usage but clearly from the photographs
there seems to be tractor movements
there
so can you confirm the sort of status of
that and also is it a public
right-of-way
uh well i can confirm it's not a public
right-of-way that access
in terms of
its use
i'm aware that
whilst there is potential use for
agricultural vehicles it's
possibly not
not wide enough in terms of scale and as
i understand from local knowledge and
the ward member
agricultural vehicles do tend to access
the site via the hockey hill estate and
using the area of the existing garages
to access the field now i understand
that the
applicant's agent has a bit more
information on that
if you would care to ask them at the
appropriate time thank you
thank you very much council mayor please
just um
online for me can you confirm that the
joint local plan 98 had this allocated
as a for development
and the latest iteration of the joint
local plan
does not have it allocated for
development
um yes the the current development plan
shows the site lying within the
settlement boundary of the village and
it was also allocated in 1998
as a site from development
i do not believe that that allocation
was taken forward since 2009 since the
policies were saved we went through that
process
and yes i can confirm that in the
emerging joint michael plan it's not
proposed to include the site area within
the
emerging plan settlement boundary but we
are working from the existing plan at
present i think that would be the advice
thank you
thank you chair
um well my question about joint local
plan has just been asked but this
appears to be
perhaps a little bit of a landlocked
site where would the emergency vehicle
access be please
um well there is proposed only to be a
single vehicular access to the site that
would be via the hockey hell estate and
the access as proposed um
i believe it's suitable for emergency
service vehicles it would be a state
road of an appropriate width it's been
considered by highways i believe and um
yeah considered acceptable for those
those purposes um it's not in a state of
uh
a scale we would need a secondary or
emergency access at all if that's
if that's a concern
but suitable
thank you chair uh i'm not sure why it's
a planning matter but the um oh i'm
assuming the garages are
rented by hockey hill
residents
and
not not owned by specific
residents
i
don't have that information i'm afraid
cancer warboys but um
yes i mean it it's they're managed by uh
mid-south estates it's all all i know i
don't know details of ownership of uh
yes
i think
that there's a
there's a bit of a contradiction that
one
the parish council has talked about a
shortage
of parking but the
also in the papers it says that the
use of the garages isn't hundred percent
uh just on the ownership issue according
to our records they're all owned by us
that's obviously that might not be 100
accurate because we're it's a different
department but ultimately what we have
access to it says they're all owned and
the land surrounding those garages are
part of mid-suffolk district council uh
obviously that's miss suffolk district
council as landowner we're dealing with
this site as local planning authority
thank you
yeah thank you chair uh
it's a slightly unusual application
because normally you get an outline
application an awful lot of stuff is
held back
uh
and it's not rather like being arrested
you have to
you know
if you want to rely on something later
you've got to say no there's there's an
could i just have confirmed
what what is held back for reserve
matters because re reading the title and
the plans it looks like we've got the
access
the layout the scale we've got a
proposed site layout so could i just
have confirmed
exactly what it is we'll be deciding
today and what will be left for any
reserve matters thank you
um yes yes i'll just just provide that
broadly if i may so um yes
this is an outline application however
matters of access layout and scale are
full consideration so that layout plan
you saw
before you
the layout as part of that is is
proposed the only matter which is
reserved would be landscaping so we
don't have the finite detail of the hard
and soft landscaping
um the scale of the dwellings is
as proposed um so um
yeah if they are indicated to be
two-story dwellings that's what uh we
would expect to come forward in terms of
reserve matters what is
not for consideration today would be the
appearance
now that would be elevations and floor
plans of the
individual buildings themselves
that's helpful
okay uh council mayor did you have a
question please um
the council owns part of the site is
that just garages or is it
the um
area on which given the main development
area as well
so i just suppose you can just put the
powerpoint back on and just put the
block plan on
just might help
right so um at the top of the plan you
have this white strip which is the
agricultural land that would remain and
essentially almost like a bridge across
it is a road that would link this site
to the state
on the northern side there that entire
piece that is owned by mid-suffolk
district council and that is
the garaging at the moment everything to
the south of that
is uh
is not part of the council uh it is uh
the developer um
and in terms of going back to the
earlier question in terms of what's
included so we don't know what these
buildings look like at all
we can probably guess what they might
look like but in terms of the actual
external appearance we don't have that
before us that's something for later
the indicative trees on that plan and
what fences may divide these properties
again they are soft and hard landscaping
elements you sort of remove those from
your mind they will be part of the
reserve matters but in terms of our
placement of those garages and buildings
uh the roads the paths they are
essentially before you
just consider right now
i hope that clarifies
question alex is regarding those garages
and obviously the replacement of those
garages with parking spaces will those
parking spaces be for the residents that
currently use those garages
yes i believe so sure yes and uh there's
a little bit of increased parking there
as well so yes
thank you very much indeed any more
questions from members
no okay then thank you very much i'll
now move on to the public speakers
and i would no like to ask the parish
council to speak uh elizabeth kane
please
if you'd like to come to the um front
seat
you have three minutes to address the
committee thank you
whenever you're ready mrs kane thank you
thank you for having me today to
represent the parish council
uh weathering set parish council or the
members president of the meeting when we
decided
we decided unanimously
uh to recommend refusal of these plans
um
i'm disappointed in the planning
office's representation of our
objections because i don't think they've
been sufficiently
strongly made
in certain points
we know that mid-suffolk district
council has an excess of five-year
housing supply
the site is not included as we've
already mentioned in the msdc draft
local plan
the proposal is not sustainable
there are no facilities whatsoever in
weathering set at all there is a primary
school a church which is only open once
a month
and
and a graveyard and that's it
all health centers public transport
shopping cannot be accessed by foot
everything will be needed access by car
and on the assumption that 14 houses
each house has probably two
vehicles that's 28
additional vehicles traveling through
the village
through a pinch point on hockey hill
we've already focused development for
the parish elsewhere we're not against
development and on brockford street
which is has direct access onto the a140
and is far more suitable
to gain access to the site
the proposal involves the demolition of
12 hockey hills residence garages and as
far as i'm aware they're only going to
be replaced by seven parking spaces
the hockey hill cul-de-sac is already
short of car parking spaces if you go
there on a weekend you can't even get in
there let alone park there
and the loss of four parking
spaces disabled and garage places will
severely impact on the existing existing
residents
the current infrastructure would be
unable to cope with increased surface
water disposal onto hockey hill uh
several times the village is
inaccessible by the main road uh the the
road at the bottom of hockey hill
there's so much flooding you can't
actually drive along there
um
and
the excess vehicles accessing will add
to the existing congestion
uh and all those residents will lose
their garages and during school times
the the
the
people drop off children and they it's
an absolute nightmare to drive along and
it's very difficult to drive along there
even on a sunday i drove along there on
sunday and it's dangerous because
everybody parks on the road um the
access to the mainland a140 where all
the services are and where the local
nearest shop is which is 1.3 miles away
is down narrow roads with sharp bends
which only have parkings
which only have parting spaces
so all the focus for the council's new
development is on the a140
um
that's it that'll do thank you thank you
very much indeed mrs k do we have any
questions for mrs kane please remember
counselor melon please
um yes thank you chair um
you mentioned that the parish had sort
of uh approved or or designated land on
brockford street yes for development
um i'm just trying to understand in my
mind where that is is that the other
side of the a140 uh it's on the same
side of the a140
if you're approaching
uh from ipswich
as you turn into the main entrance into
weathering set which is cedars hill
it's the field immediately as you turn
into cedars hill from the road it's on
the left of there it's a big field and
it's owned by the same landowner owner
any other questions from members
uh councillor mayor please
not for the
councillor but for the officer um
are there any other areas in weathering
set that are in the the emerging joint
local plan as a set aside for
development
um yeah yes i believe uh
profit street is the preference locally
for the focus of development yeah that's
included
already being developed in brockford
street nine houses on the main on the
main
road thank you very much uh chair and
again really a question for the officer
prompted by
um the parish representation which is
about the number of parking spaces
uh
so can you confirm that there is no net
loss of the number of parking spaces
so yeah as i understand there will be 12
of so there are 12 garages as existing
and it's proposed to provide um
six seven so eight there
and nine ten
11 12
13 i make it
counsellor with with four disabled
sized bays also available
housing estate and the existing
residence that's not exactly the same
but it would be available for um
for parking for the existing estate as i
understand
it's not specifically for the proposed
development not designated but but
available
um
no i don't believe it's specifically
designated but it would be available for
uh
or generally yeah
did you wish to come in
uh i was actually gonna pick up the
parking point but alex has essentially
answered that which is they are open to
anyone's use those parking spaces so
they're essentially their visitor
parking if you were looking at it in a
standard estate way
i was just going to confirm that in
terms of the emerging joint local plan
um obviously weathering set compared it
has got various settlement boundaries
but in terms of the allocations
proposed there is two and they are only
in brockford street uh area itself
um
obviously
at the current time the current local
plan uh has this site within the
settlement boundary for a secondary
village
that is the status that we are
adopted at this current time
but obviously members can give
limited weight to the emerging local
plan that doesn't have this site within
any allocation or within the settlement
boundary although it would be adjacent
to the proposed settlement boundary
for this
cluster
but if that helps thank you very much
any other questions from members
can i just ask
mrs kane if i made these um are you
aware that these garages are currently
occupied by existing residents they're
all of them hi
thank you very much
okay
if there are no more questions for mrs
kane thank you very much for your
contribution this morning i'd lay like
to
ask an objective of speaker mr mike
pease and mr pease you have three
minutes to address the committee thank
you
thank you chair
um a couple of minor detail points the
um hockey hill cul de sac is not an
estate
what this development would create
is effectively an estate
it's out of character with the village
it's in entirely the wrong location
because it puts effectively 25
of additional capacity in an already
developed area of the village
the joint local plan highlighted areas
where preferred development should take
place i.e brockford street
it will have a considerable
adverse impact on hockey hill residents
the traffic
which is quite bad will get
worse
i'm not talking about
traffic jams all the time but at peak
times it is quite bad
the agricultural access
highlighted on the plan is used it's the
best access to the large field behind
for the larger agricultural vehicles
the only other access is along town lane
which is too narrow for the largest
combines
as
council of kansas already stated we have
a junior school we have a church we
actually have a friday social club at
the mid-suffolk um
museum railway museum
no public transport no shops no doctor
no dentist no pub everything requires
vehicular
access to those facilities
the residents welcome
new housing in the village specifically
affordable homes to villages
but in the right location
brockford street was identified as the
correct location which is why it's on
the joint local plan
twelve garages are being removed
seven parking spaces
in that area are being provided
regardless of what's claimed to be laid
out in this um outline
planning permission
we have a therefore a loss of five
parking spaces
the access into the hockey hill
cul-de-sac is congested
the bungalows
which form the entrance to it
have people parking outside
all the time
i think that really sums it up
it's a good
development but it's the wrong location
brockford street is the perfect location
for this
it's owned by the applicant we would
endorse it
we don't
endorse location in an already crowded
area of the village
thank you for your time thank you do
members have any questions for mr peace
please
counselor melon please
um yes um
i hope you can just confirm the
the public transport because we were
pointed out i think in the presentation
at a bus stop are you saying there's no
buses at all they are
the only buses in wetherington are
school buses there used to be a bus
service probably about seven or eight
years ago that no longer runs there is
no
public transport in the village other
than dialer ride which is
well wait for a while until one finally
arrives
so yeah cancer melons just asked my
question thank you
are there any more questions please for
mr peace
no thank you very much mr peace
contribution this morning
um can i now move on to the agents um
sarah hucklesby and tony olston please
okay yeah we just have a wipe the tables
down before you
check your seats
look at me
thank you very much thank you very much
to both of you who coming today between
you you have three minutes i'll start
the timer now thank you
thank you for the opportunity speaking
to you um i feel some information
regarding the background and reasoning
behind this application may be of
assistance to you
this particular parcel of land has been
owned and run by the dr olsen world
trust for over 100 years
since the early past the last century
this area is classed as grade 3
agricultural land and has not been
farmed actively for some considerable
time
it's difficult land to cultivate
the configuration has always meant it's
too small for the size of agricultural
vehicles used on the farm
in addition the site is surrounded on
three sides by dwellings and within such
a confined space the density and types
of methods necessary to support and
enhance viable growth would be
unacceptable
part of the original parcel of land was
sold by mr donald alston to a local
builder mr eric scott in the late 1970s
the bungalows facing hockey hill was
subsequently constructed to circa 1979
and drainage not overhead power lines
i'm afraid were installed on the east
side thereby allowing for future
connection
it was always both party's intention
that the remaining land should be used
for housing and it was incorporated
within the village envelope and
designated as such for development in
the local plan of 1998. it is not
included as immunity space within the
current
mid 2013-36
open space assessment
the aim of this application is to
provide a variety of modest sized homes
to serve the needs of the village in the
rural community generally
therefore this outline application has
been very carefully considered on the
basis of local needs using the character
and type of building surrounding the
land as a guide
the field accesses have been in
existence since before the bungalows
were built there have been no issues in
the past with this minor route the main
access to the large field behind the
site is from the east and south and the
access via hockey hill will not be used
any more frequently than at present
in relation to the loss of garaging
mid-south estates have requested that 12
parking spaces as a minimum be provided
as an alternative as they felt the
existing garages are past their useful
life are too small for modern vehicles
and offer little relief for parking on
this part of hockey hill it was their
request the garages were removed not
ours
the location number and type of parking
spaces are subject to a draft legal
agreement which has accordingly been
prepared and agreed with the applicants
we've worked with strategic housing to
agree the type and layout of affordable
housing on the southeast corner of the
site at their request the final proposal
has two parking spaces per unit where
adjacent to these dwellings accessed by
the shared surface shown
finally i'd like to reiterate this
proposal for development has been
generated by a local family also a local
employer who aren't always have been
very keen to see that weathering set
thrives as a village
the intention of building on this land
to meet local needs goes back over 50
years and although both the original
instigators of the project have now
passed on it is their legacy and their
wish to keep the village alive that
remains and has been carried on with the
present application by their successors
thank you and i'll take any questions
okay
mr peyton mcgee i appreciate i'm not a
member but i do have a question if i may
um thank you yes
and just put give me the layout again on
the back on the screen please can i just
confirm i'm a little confused um we've
been talking about this line on the
left-hand side as yeah pylon but i don't
think it is is that strange that's
strange thank you
sorry so let's confirm this another way
so that uh
relocation
of the line is actually a relocation of
drainage that's right angling water said
that that's possible so there was no
pylons going across this side
thank you
um
that was all i it seemed a bit odd after
a while because i thought well where are
we going to put the stands for the
pylons in middle people's gardens it
didn't make any sense so thank you for
confirming that it is an apologies from
our point of view as well for not
pointing that out earlier um thank you
oh last question sorry one last thing
you mentioned legal agreement i see we
mean a legal agreement between the
council as landowner and yourself in
terms of the parking but that's not
anything to do with the planning
decision nothing to do with the planning
it's expensive completely separate
agreement
if there are no further questions for
the agents thank you very much for your
contribution today we don't have a
supporter
or so i will now ask the ward member to
speak uh councillor andrew stringer over
to you please
thank you chair uh
this is one of those cases where you you
see the sort of
when planning becomes slightly perverse
because of timing
this particular site i believe was a
bigger site in the upcoming 1998 local
plan and it went to
an appeal i believe and was restricted
to the size it is shown in the 1998
local fan so it's been in the
current local plan since 1998
but never built out during that time
so when the village was consulted about
where you'd like to see development in
the upcoming joint local plan
and the embryonic neighborhood plan
that's being conducted in weathering set
obviously there was a huge review about
where new housing would need to go
and that review in light of what had
changed since 1998
fully recognized that the most
sustainable location to put housing
growth in weathering set was brockford
street
because brockford street was where on
balance a number of
elements of sustainability existed
things like footpath connections to a
shop
to a bus stop and a primary road network
that that didn't exist in the center of
weathering set
so uh weathering set parish council
submitted to the joint local plan
policy department here at mid-south
district council their proposals for
future growth
and mid-suffolk agreed with their
proposal and they agreed to take this
site out of the settlement boundary
because mid-suffolk agreed that it was
an unsustainable location
in the future of the joint local plan
and the only quirk about this is
obviously the joint local plan is not
policy yet so having agreed this is an
unsustainable location
we have to agree it was sustainable back
in 1998 although never built out in that
time
so
therefore for the purposes of this we
have to look at uh a 1998 local plan
which says it was acceptable then
but it's odd that we cannot use that
old local plan
to resist new development it's it's one
of those perversities of where we find
ourselves and we're we're at the moment
in a policy limbo land if the joint
local plan were policy today and the
inspector that's looking at it this
month
agreed that all the submissions in there
were correct
this site
would not be deemed sustainable unless
unlike other sites in mid-suffolk that
were reviewed in 2003 this site was
reviewed in 2003 by the assets
department and we agreed that it should
only come forward as an exception site
for affordable housing purely affordable
housing which we did in other areas with
sites similar to this
right so
that's the sort of slightly muddy policy
element that we've got here
so if we if we're going to approve it we
rely on a 1998 plan although we know it
doesn't form part of an upcoming plan
there are some plus points about this i
mean this is almost
not an outline application as far as i
can see because we have an awful lot of
detail here other than as you said
appearance and all those finer details
we've got layout which gives us
something that we can actually work upon
so if you look at plus points uh it
looks a very reasonable design with
reasonably distanced properties
we've got the vast majority of these
plots have an element of south facing
roof that's a first well done
uh
there then we start getting into the
minus points
uh i'm gonna have to grasp the thorny
issue of parking
because we've got layout in here there
are a number of significant challenges
with the parking here
committee after committee here resists
tandem parking
almost all but four of these rely on
tandem parking to make this work
well that's one car in front of another
tandem parking we
we have resisted that at this committee
time after time especially in rural
areas because all it creates is a huge
amount of chaos to get the second car
out and there's tandem parking relied on
plot 14 13 12 because one's in the
garage and one's outside
but
it is if you can show me where the
second parking space is for those other
two because you've already said it can't
be the ones opposite them because
they're the replacement for the garages
that we're taking down and of course
that's where the other fault is in this
plan those parking spaces outside plot
13 and 12 are not going to be used as a
replacement for the demolition of the
garages why would somebody that lives in
the existing ex-council housing round
the corner park in front of someone
else's private bungalow
and then walk back round on that estate
that the frankly there isn't the
replacement parking in this design
equally about the design even if we
swallow the element of tandem parking
plot five on this plan i would really
really like to see someone try and get a
car in those
because you're right up against that
boundary and the landscaping there i
physically don't think you can get a car
in there and i know that the county
council hasn't objected but frankly
uh you know i'm yet to see the county
council object to anything
here at our planning committees so i
think the parking here is is nowhere
near what we would expect
for a rural area uh
equally we need to
uh look at the guidance on cycle storage
every single neighbor the pla the
neighborhood planning committee for this
village has been written to by the
county council to say you need a
condition in there that shows secure
cycle storage
well i cannot see where the secure cycle
storage is for plot eight seven six and
five there's nothing
so
the county council should have responded
to this
from that element as well which they
haven't done uh which i apologize for
we also need to be acutely aware as the
parish council saying the reason this
isn't in the joint local plan
that going forward is because of it it's
so far away from elements of
sustainability without much in the way
of footpaths to get you there you're 1.3
miles away
in the shortest route to walk to a bus
stop or to a village shop let alone a
public house or something like that so
it is quite a long way away from what we
would call sustainability so if you
found this acceptable in the old policy
terms it would certainly need to wash
its face significantly on that
sustainability front going forward to so
that we we do actually bring about
anything that could even claim to be
sustainable i would equally
like you to look at one of the letters
of objection
that letter objection was very balanced
but it did then go on to say if you were
going to approve this there are a number
of things that they had concerns about
and that was potential permit
development rights in those gardens of
14 13 12 and 11
and also the designs that bungalows
should be single story and try and keep
those roots to to a sensible height to
protect that residential amenity
uh i think that's all the points i
wanted to make
so i'll end and there thank you and
thank you for listening
stringer
do we have any questions please for the
ward number
no
therefore i will open up the
item for debate
thanks chad
um
for me this rests on
dates
do we rely on
uh
an individual's aspirations dating back
50 years
a local plan that is now 23 years
old
or do we rely on
an emerging plan for which there was
consultation
that supports the parish councils a
position that these houses are in the
wrong place
it's a balance and and for me
i think we should support the parish
council support the emerging joint local
plan and say these houses though they
may be a a good design are in the wrong
place
anybody else would like to enter into
the debate councillor norris please
well thank you chair um without
repeating what council mayor has just
said
to me i question whether this is really
sustainable
in the true sense of the word
um
it does seem to be in the wrong
place it's quite an admirable low in to
some extent although there are some
questions as uh councillor stringer has
raised regarding
actual
practical parking provision within the
site itself um
it seems that uh parking is going to be
exacerbated
and will become a major issue if it goes
ahead
so at the moment i'm not feeling that i
can support this application in this
location
but i will listen to the rest of the
debate thank you
patrick please
apologize i don't normally want to come
in this early into the debate to try and
assist but i'm just conscious that we've
already picked up on some policy points
so i just want to clarify a couple of
these issues um firstly um the review of
the 1998
local plan was carried out in your 2008
core strategy and ultimately at that
point your policy then defined the idea
of primary villages key service sectors
and secondary villages
this was designated as a secondary
village and its settlement boundary
was as it is right now defined at that
point
so ultimately
we're not looking at the local plan 98
it has been reviewed since then it's not
as old as you may think uh what we are
looking at is still an old document 2008
and any and in the focus review that
came along in 2012 they didn't seek to
address the settlement boundaries it
kept to the 2008 uh settlement
boundaries but just for clarity i want
you you're making a decision to
essentially set aside your current
settlement boundary policy
um
i would be very cautious about that and
i would be even considering referrals as
you would be essentially looking at
something
in conflict with your own policy to
allow in principle development within
settlement boundaries at this current
time
i appreciate that as it is all about
timing and planning the uh
proposed
emerging joint local plan which is not
your current adopted policy
does say something different in terms of
settlement boundaries
but
i would urge members to be very careful
about the weight given to that in the
context that to do the other would be
conflicting with the provisions of your
own adopted a local plan which includes
the core strategy
just to pick up on a couple other points
um cycle secure cycle storage if
ultimately you wish to see that that can
be an additional condition to be placed
on this application
if you are looking at the 12 replacement
parking for residents bearing in mind
what you open said that there's already
a legal agreement between the council as
a landowner to secure those but in
planning terms if you feel it's
essential as a planning issue there is
no reason why that could not also be
secured in planning terms
and also the other one mentioned was
removal of permitted development rights
i noticed actually it's not included in
our list of conditions and i would
actually quite willingly add that
to the proposal as well
and i'll leave it there for the time
being thank you
right members uh would anyone else like
to continue to debate
thanks um
thanks chad and i
i guess i'm
slightly more concerned or confused um
as a consequence of mr paytman g's
advice than i thought
i was a moment ago um
certainly in terms of the
uh
the the local plan the emerging local
plan i mean we
my impression is that we
uh make increasing uh reference to that
as that accrues
um
status as it were
uh as it goes through the process and it
is hopefully nearing
the end of that process
but what is in there
does reflect
current thinking and views
and therefore
to put that aside in favor of
an older plan even one that was
reviewed um
within the past decade
um
seems to me to be slightly uh slightly
odd that that um planning rules allow
surely we should go with what our
current assessment
um
what our current assessment of need and
allocation is
so i'm
you know instinctively i i would say
drawn towards what
we now think
in terms of uh
sites for development rather than what
we may have thought in the past but i i
have learned though it still baffles me
i have learned that planning is not as
is not as simple as that so may need
advice from that point
in terms of the
uh
the seems
clear
to me that there would be better sites
for for
for this development than here and there
are some real challenges about
sustainability uh of of the site
uh having said that um the site the
proposal uh has many virtues uh not
least in terms of the provision of
bungalows uh
in particular and affordable homes which
so often
uh crop up in our consideration of
applications where we were we wish there
were more of both
so the provision of those in this
proposal uh i think is is is very
welcome uh again the as is being said
the the layout uh of this site
uh
seems very attractive
um
there's nothing much to argue about
there
i think the realities of of competitive
parking
may well mean that those who currently
have
have space
aren't you know lose out i can i can see
that being
highly likely so i'm by myself um
i suppose in a position as councilor
mayor and captain norissa of while
seeing the virtues within the
application
actually being concerned about the
sustainability of the of the site
and then
found myself dependent on advice
about the application of planning policy
to support
to support that position thank you
um do you have something to add uh
counter-stringer for information it's
coming off the back of
what uh
mr peyton g said uh mr paperman was
mentioning about the how we we shouldn't
vary from the 1998 local plan and the
enshrinement in the core strategy review
of the settlement boundary
when looking at this case but it's
important to note that we did
discount those two policies when we
approved outline one of the sites that's
in the upcoming joint local plan
so it seems that you can adhere to the
local 1998 and core strategy settlement
boundary if it's approving houses
but you can ignore it when you want to
approve more houses
so what i'm telling you is one of those
sites in the upcoming joint local plan
in brockford street already has outlined
planning permission
so we're already quite a way down the
road so what we're so what the village
is now being told by
this application is you'll not have one
or the other you'll have both
electrically charged vehicles
if we demolish the garages that denies
them the ability to charge their cars
i don't have the answer to that i'm not
aware of that
um first of all i do not wish to tell
members what to do at all so forgive me
if that it was the impression that
you've got
ultimately i'm asking to be very careful
with the balance but the balance
ultimately is yours to make
in terms of
the position in terms of the current
policy obviously things have moved on
from the joint local platform so again
from the core strategy and the local
plan um not least due to the national
planning policy framework uh introduced
in 2012 and has been updated many times
since and it might be if you are looking
at that in terms of sustainability uh
that you may wish to
look further at the joint uh look at the
national planning policy framework and
the context of for example
paragraph 80 of the updated version this
year in terms of looking at
sustainability of this site and will
argue that to say that that is why
despite your current policy position you
have sought to move on it just it just
leaving it to the emerging local plan
only
would in my view provide a risk that is
an opportunity at appeal
you need you know we need to be careful
about how we look at that issue
unless my colleague would like to add
more
chairman can i just say something about
this just just so we're absolutely clear
about this the draft joint local plan is
presently at examination it is
presumptuous for us to
assume that the examiner will find it
either sound or unsound
and
we advise committee in development
control decisions
to consider
that that plan has limited weight
so where does that leave you you have a
development plan
which is the 1998 local plan with
various saved elements
and you have
the
uh core strategy and course strategy
focus drew and perhaps unhelpfully as mr
patron g has said you've also got the
nppf to weigh in this so you have a
blend of those things and
no one
of those documents provides
a
clear solution
to which is the right document but what
i would say is that
i do not advise you
to attach more than limited weight
to the draft joint local plan because it
has not
passed through
the examination it is undergoing and
i'm perhaps trying to lay on heavier
than john has put it here because
that carries risk you have
the presumption in favor of sustainable
development to apply here which is in
the nppf and which has been rehearsed
before
i think
together with your saved policies you
can consider quite adequately whether or
not this represents
sustainable development in the
connection in connection with that and
john has referred to you two elements of
the nppf which refer to that
but i think it would be unwise to unduly
rely upon the discussion of various past
reviews of things
or indeed to rely upon the future plan i
think you have your policies
and you have the nppf and i would
suggest those are the things that you
should be drawn to thank you chairman
members do you wish um casey mellon
please
thank you chair um yeah i'm grateful to
the officers for that those
clarifications um
the mppf was what i was going to come to
anyway i'm glad that mr patman g brought
it up because that is the the difference
um from from the core
review 2008 we have that that's come in
so that seems to me to be the
sort of change in policy that we might
be able to
um rely on here
i mean i'm just so aware that often
we're told that our policies are out of
date and we can't rely on them and yet
we seem to be here
seeking to
um look back to those old policies
paragraph 103 of the mppf talks about
limiting the need for travel and
offering a genuine choice of transport
modes
and
it seems to me that is a a fairly
significant
paragraph i'm not sure what it is
actually in the new mppf
um but to my mind this this site seems
to be
um
in the context of other applications
that we've refused recently
a place which is unsustainable in terms
of it's its
proximity to services
um
being able to access services in a
sustainable way
um so that's where i am at the moment
thank you chad
so the updated policy reference is what
uh paragraph 105
in
that it talks about how the planning
system should manage uh patterns of
growth in support of objectives it does
refer more to significant development
and obviously
the phrase significant does that apply
to this but then significant in the
context of the village you can weigh
that up
ultimately you may want to look further
at
paragraph 79
which refers to and if i may just find
the point
where you are looking at sort of
enhancing maintaining the viability of
the rural community and talks it talks
in part about unsustainable traffic
movements for future residents
um which wouldn't be supported by local
services so it's about the viability of
this particular sustainability of this
location so it might be a case of
looking at that further
boys then council may then catch the
bird yes um
thank you it
uh
i respect um
[Music]
mr peyton g's comments and making this a
little bit more palatable with regards
to
maintaining the existence of garage in
for
the residents there's a there's a huge
amount of difference between a garrett
having a garage
and a
non-designated parking space
and again the sort of
withdrawal of sort of development
possibilities in the gardens and the
provision of cycle storage
which leaves a tandem parking which
looking at this current layout
um
would be difficult to
mitigate
however i think what what
sticks for me on this planet is is that
its sustainability and its location
we've heard from the parish council
and a member of the public and it's
quite clear that the
the communities in favor of development
but not in this site
and
looking at the
mppf which sort of trumps
the 2008
revision of the local plan
planning policies and decisions should
be responsible to local circumstances
and support housing developments that
reflect local needs which i feel the
parish council has identified very
clearly for us and
their proposals
and it goes on as mr paper g says
promotes
we should be promoting sustainable
development in rural areas
um things have changed quite
dramatically since 2008 in terms of
our um appreciation of
of how
important sustainability is is going to
be a present and in future we do need to
be looking at
if you like future proof developments
and future proof housing and um
i think
we should be aware of the present
situation and
rather than sort of relying upon
making a decision based on something
which is now
wait do some calculations quickly
12 13 years old
that's
that's the way my thoughts are moving at
the moment that we should try and
have a contemporary solution here
thanks chuck
i think we need to be careful about uh
relying on paragraph 105
in terms of
sustainability and transport whether the
the site is
as proposed or whether it's on brockford
street would still need to use vehicles
to access um local facilities
so i i was encouraged when mr g
mentioned para 79 and for me that seems
to be the crux of the matter um the
parish council want this development in
a sustainable location in that they're
protecting their village and by moving
it to brockford street not allowing it
here we
we would be protecting rural community
in that the increased traffic
would not be forced to use the rural
center
so i i would focus on paris 79 rather
than 105.
please
yes thank you
excuse me thank you chairman um
quite a lot of what i've been thinking
has been
been said already uh i mean
it is unfortunate that the waters are
currently all well always muddied at the
moment by the conflict that that we have
between our
um
existing
uh local plan the adopted local plan and
the emerging local plan
yes we do have to um
balance the waiting we give as a as a
committee to to those those two
um
those two plans
uh
i tend to agree
that it's probably
better to take
leave that decision to to the to the
national planning policy framework
and um
where we have the presumption in favor
of
uh sustainable development and the key
is
uh is is this sustainable
development in a sustainable location
the the parking the garaging etc has
been
quite an issue during the course of this
debate and i
i tend to agree with the way members are
feeling about it
um
i welcome the
inclusion of uh
dedicated disabled parking spaces in in
the new design
i do think that it is unlikely that any
of the present occupiers of the
garaging will
consider that any of the parking spaces
within this uh within this development
apart from those at the very
entrance
to the site will be um much used to them
parking spaces versus garages well i do
wonder
uh to what extent the existing garages
are used to park vehicles or to uh store
materials that are spilling out from the
various houses which is a a
fairly standard
standard thing
so i think i think overall the the
the loss of parking spaces
if one includes the original the
existing garaging as
genuine parking spaces is unfortunate
the tandem parking too is unfortunate
um
so i think i'm very
veering towards the sustainability
of of the site
as the most important feature that we
should be concentrating on today
thank you
um i'm about to have my two pennies
worth now i must know i found the actual
debate very very interesting and thank
you all for your comments so far
i too are moving towards the sustainable
development
as we know and the
parish clerk is actually in formless of
this in the upcoming
local plan there are areas within this
village
located for
housing which the parish towns are happy
with they're not happy with this
particular location although i take into
account what the chief planning officer
and the area planning manager has said
also
i was also looking at paragraph 80 in
the new version of the nppf which says
planning policies and decisions should
avoid the development of isolated homes
in the countryside unless one or more of
the following circumstances apply
now
my concern there is the term isolated
homes because
uh if i could seek advice from mr duprey
on this particular one from a legal
perspective
because i wouldn't personally say that
this was isolated because it's just not
one-off thing so
would that be a correct way
i'd be happy to advise you but perhaps
my planner's colleagues should go first
i'll have if i need anything thank you
um
a bit of a can of worms this one so i
don't know it explains too much but
ultimately this has been a matter of
course over the word isolated um and
when it comes down to it it is taken to
be the the plain english definition of
it which is
in this context would not deem this to
be isolated given the fact that you have
got an existing settlement all the way
around this site uh virtually all around
this side um it would be very difficult
to argue that this is truly isolated in
that context so i would certainly not
advise you that this is isolated uh i
would not seek to employ uh paragraph 80
in the context of this site um i would
stick to where we've discussed already
please think thank you for that mr
pimaji that was really what i was
thinking myself and you've basically
confirmed that and thank you so much i
endorse that don't need to have anything
yeah so thank you for that right do any
other members wish to add anything to
the actual
debate
before we move on like to move this on
no we've debated this in some style now
would anyone any member like to make a
proposal on this particular application
because we do need to move this forward
okay
please
i propose that we
refuse this application on the basis of
sustainability
revolving around paragraph nine of the
mppf
um and supported by the emerging joint
likelihood plan
okay thank you so we have a proposal for
refusal do we have a second effort if
you freezal
okay so melon
yeah thank you chair this is a tricky
case there's no doubt about it um
and
i would like us to be on
solid policy ground
because you know there's the fear of an
appeal um but i think the
the paragraph um
79 was it i think in
i've got the new mppf net up now
um
would would seem to
fit this
this one where we've got
potential locations elsewhere in the
village which will enhance and maintain
the vitality of a rural community
and and the question mark is is over
this site whether it will
um
there's there's clearly some things that
this site is bringing it's bringing some
houses to a rural area it's bringing
some
bungalows
and some affordables
but to my mind it doesn't outweigh the
fact that um
it's it's not a sustainable location
that i can as i can see so i'm happy to
second
councilman willis proposal thank you
very much indeed uh councilman
does anyone else wish to make any
further comment
uh
could i ask mr peyton g please
uh so obviously um i have been listening
to the debate and and typing away
to think about what a potential reason
for refusal or reasons
may look like
my suggestion for members to consider
would be to delegate to the chief
planning officer to refuse the proposed
development on the following grounds
that the proposed development would be
located in part of the parish
where it would not
enhance or maintain the viability of
this rural community and would generate
unsustainable traffic movements for from
future residents
which would not support local services
on that basis the development would be
contrary to paragraph 79 of the nppf
now whether you wish to take that's one
step further in the context of
furthermore the proposal would not meet
the objectives of paragraphs 104 and 105
by limiting opportunities to promote
walking cycling and public transport in
this countryside location
so there's two parts to that take both
take one i'll leave that for further
debate if need be or take you forward
uh with mr peyton g's comments for the
refusal
yes i struggled to see
how 105 would add very much to this
i can take that out
are you would you be content that it
still limits opportunities to promote
walking cycling public transport or do
you want the whole of 104 and 105 out
and would you stick to the viability
i don't see how that how it does
so we are
just looking at then the the first part
of what i said uh in respect of um not
enhancing maintaining the viability of
the rural community uh unsustainable
traffic movements and looking at
paragraph 79 of the mppf
should we not include
and
the emerging joint local plan could that
add some weight or do one feel that
should not be referred to at all
i did avoid that purposely if i'm honest
that's your decision but i would need
more information to see how to pull that
in
i appreciate it's outside the emerging
settlement boundaries but as my
uh line manager says uh ultimately
we need to be very careful here in in
context of it is a presumption that we
are taking that could be a risk
okay yeah happy thank you counselor
melon are you happy with the uh comments
from mr pate mcgee um yeah um i mean i
think i'd like to see 104 in there but
i'll go with councillor milan thank you
thank you very much yes um personally um
i am not in favor of this application i
do agree with my colleagues about the
sustainable thing and i would have voted
against
granting this particular one
planning permission on this case does
anyone else wish to make any comment
before we go to the vote
so if i can just interrupt yes apologies
um just to be clear i did also save to
delegate to the chief planning officer
purposefully in this case just to enable
us to add any further reasons as we see
fit if necessary if that's okay
yes thank you jason mellon are you happy
with that as well yes thank you very
much then i will now ask the governor's
officer please to start the voting on
the comments made before
thank you chair what i was going to
suggest is if uh mr payment could just
read out what he was agreed against that
we're all completely clear
on what we're voting on and then i'll
put it in the vote as read out by the
area planning manager if that's except
that's fine thank you very much
right so from the top uh so to delegate
to the chief planning officer to refuse
the proposed development the police
development would be located in part of
the parish where it would not enhance or
maintain the viability of this rural
community and would generate
unsustainable
traffic movements from future residents
which would not support local services
on that basis the development would
contrary to paragraph 79 of the nppf
and we would have a
discretion to add any further reason as
we see fit on that basis thank you
just for myself from the general public
you did say earlier that if the
committee reminded to refuse that you
would recommend this go to referrals
committee because you felt it a perverse
decision is that still the case
i have not sought to pursue that in the
end no
thank you
thank you chair so members will now note
that the vote is now in progress if
members could please go to the
modern.gov app it will now show in a
light blue color counselor david burke
can i please take your vote verbally
please
four four thank you
just to know as well that um under the
um rules of mid suffolk district
council's planning charter the board
member council stringer cannot vote so
if any information of public watching
oh let me try that again
is it working now
fantastic
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is unanimous vote for
the proposal of refusal thank you
right um
item 7c
dc stroke 21 stroke 00 782
wingfield barnes church road wingfield
suffolk
i'd like to invite
the case officer who will be mr payment
g to introduce the application to the
committee
mr patrick g thank you
thank you so i'm afraid the case officer
wasn't able to make this meeting so i've
taken the next two items
to present um just to clarify there's
two in wingfield so the one with first
of all we're dealing with is application
uh with the 72 sorry 782 at the end
which is change of use for the from the
performing studio to an office under
class e
so to start with uh some area
photographs this is the wingfield barnes
complex
complex of former
farm buildings converted into a visual
and performing arts center
in the late 1990s i believe and the site
is currently entirely owned as we
understand by mid suffolk district
council hence why it is before you today
the subject building is a single story
traditional barn i just indicated on red
on that
overhead
it's a single saw building with a brick
lymph and
pantile roof
and weatherboarded and painted white
the proposal is for the change of view
so that building with no external or
internal alterations this is just pure
change of use of its use
so
put into context that's where we are we
are
fairly remote
and that's the red line around the
pacific building that the change of use
refers to and the rest of the site which
is
owned
by miss suffolk is in blue
now we have um
the constraints map we've got a tree
preservation order on some trees in this
area here we've got a grade two listed
building here grade two star
to the uh to the north uh this specific
building
isn't listed in its own right
and ultimately we are all in within a
conservation area as well
that's the floor plan
of the current arrangement which is not
sought to be changed
and that's the building in front in
question and i've got some photos sorry
skip one
that's the building to be changed of you
to an office
that's it
um right
um i was just going to conclude sorry
think of me there's a couple of things i
need to add
so ultimately it's just change of use we
don't feel there's any significant
planning harm identified by the proposal
uh having regard to its current use and
proposed use um there is a change in
your late papers though to the
recommendation i need to mention um
which has been tabled essentially there
is a 106 agreement on the entire site
that controls the use
we do need to check
because it was raised later in the day
by us
we need to check that it doesn't need to
be first altered to enable this change
of use to take place and if it does need
to be altered we need a moment to do
that before we release any decision made
so if if you are looking to approve
the application we would then go away
and just check the 106 and sort that out
before issuing any such resolution so
just to clarify that
and i don't know if any members are
aware of class e but
just to update this is a relatively
recent change to the general committed
development order
where a lot of the other
classes of use got amalgamated into one
larger use so class e does cover a range
of uses everything from
display of retail of goods uh
professional services indoor sport
and nurseries and day center and so on
but it does include office use and in
this particular case in your
recommendation we've restricted this
change of use to just that one office
use so it doesn't broaden out into the
other users
so that is a specific restriction of
permitted development that is on your
recommendation sorry sherman that was
all i just needed to add thank you very
much to payment um members do you have
any questions please for the mr payton g
uh council of war boys please
um yes this um the um
following um
proposal
um i am i'm a little bit concerned i'm
familiar with winfield barnes as a an
arts center
and i'm aware that the the buildings
were developed to provide quite a unique
cultural center cultural asset in
mid-suffolk
and
i am concerned that the sort of
redesignation of part of this asset and
the collection of buildings has office
space would diminish that
ability to
act as a
as a an arts venue
in fairness i don't know if i can help
you with that question um i'm not sure
this office is in association with the
art center or if it's an independent
office um unfortunately i'm i'm not
aware of the motivations only that it is
being proposed as an office
from a studio so you are looking at a
loss of the studio space
for an office space
ins instead
although part of the looking at the
block plan part of it was already being
used as an office already
looking at the block plan but
there is a yeah there is a possible
reduction of studio space as a
consequence of the the decision if made
um i will also point out it's not the
first time though for this complex we
have had a day nursery uh approved
within the complex uh a couple of years
ago
so there has been changes since the 90s
when that the whole rock was a
performing arts studio
anyone else have any questions for the
mr payment g
no
okay thank you very much indeed
um
right we don't actually have an objector
supporter or agent but we do have a
comment from the ward member council of
lavinia hattingham which i will ask the
governor's office to read
thank you chair um just as well to point
out as mobiles will know in their table
papers there is a comment from the
parish council um as well so just to
draw that to mum's attention so from the
ward member councillor lavinia hadingham
and she has written i will not be
attending the development control b
meeting on the first of september so
could you please pass on my apologies
for not attending as ward member for the
items regarding wingfield barnes and
could you please pass on to the
committee that i give both items my full
support thank you kind of god loving you
having him thank you
thank you
for i would open up the item to debate
counselor stringer thank you chair uh
yeah i mean
it's basically
uh yes there is a potential loss of
workshop space on studio space but
within the diversification
of something like this i'd imagine it
will need to secure
a level of income from something
that possibly isn't studio or what have
you and and frankly i'm surprised it's
not permitted development what what's
proposed here so i i i don't think
we're stopping it being used as a studio
perhaps in the future or what have you
but if it does help with the
diversification
and give give the people that run it
another option then i really don't have
a huge problem with it so i i would move
approval as per recommendation amended
thank you very much uh
uh chair i i
actually don't
know
whether this is office space to support
the arts activities or whether it's to
provide
a rental stream
which
would support provision of art
activities from this site so it is
important that the site remains
viable
i know that there
has been some new recruitment
uh and certainly a
um
a new determination uh to succeed into
provision of arts
at that what is a lovely
a lovely location well loved location so
um having said that i would uh wish to
support this this
application uh
and um
i'm not sure it's been proposed
well if it's been proposed i'd like to
second
uh support thank you
mayor
my thunder has been stolen
thank you very much indeed yes does
anybody else wish to speak on this one
no
i too actually are actually in favor of
this one
so i will be supporting this particular
application we've had a proposal and a
seconder and the recommendation is as
the amended version which character
stringer and mr peyton g
mentioned
therefore i will now ask the
governance officer to start the
electronic vote please
thank you chair
so the recommendation as in uh mongov
will read the application
dc21007a2 be approved as detailed in the
updated officer recommendations that
includes the part of the table papers as
read out
so
the vote is now in progress members
if you go to the government and
go to the plus side in the top right
hand corner and go to the blue line
showing the vote in progress
and i'll just ask councillor david
please take your vote please
unfold this afterwards thank you
you
council stringer is it
no okay could i take your vote verbally
please
thank you
thank you chair all votes have now been
received so that is seven votes four and
one against the motion is carried thank
you very much indeed thank you
right in that case we'll move straight
on to the item 7d which is dc stroke 21
stroke 02116 again wingfield barnes
church road wingfield suffolk and i will
again invite the case officer mr
patemanji to introduce the application
to the committee thank you
thank you so this one is also at
wingfield this is the changing use of
the granary this time
and it's from occasional residential use
as um as it stands to class
e i'll go into that in a detail in a
moment
again we are at wingfield barnes this
time um we are at the rear of more
towards the rear of the site as
indicated on the aerial photograph above
um
we already know this is a an arts and a
performing arts center um and we already
know this is entirely owned by the
council at the moment
the granary is a traditional timber
frame building
with a brick pimp with pitch pantal roof
again walls weatherboarded again we'll
see those in the photographs in a moment
originally
converted to provide accommodation for
visiting artists
it has since been approved for a day
nursery as well although i'm not sure
that's been implemented so this change
of use is for the change of use of
residential occasional residential use
essentially to class e
um
just to go through the constraints we
are now at the rear of the grade two uh
listen to building one mouse this one
um that's the the tpos again that's the
grade two star listed building uh just
to put that in context
and that's the building we're talking
about this time
again not too
big at all quite modest
i'll leave it there
so again this is a change of use with no
changes externally or um internally
it's purely down to the the use itself
essentially
we look at the report and we're looking
at the environmental health officers
response which is on page 348.
so essentially we were looking to say
yes we'll accept this change to the
general
class e but clancy as i mentioned before
is quite wide and so we are looking to
say that this will be for financial
services professional services
um for crash day uh nursery day center
and offices
for the copyright for administration
functions and this would be conditioned
again uh in respect of
this application
uh so we we've already previously
granted essentially the day nursery part
of this once before
this is essentially an expansion of that
to allow for offer use a more flexible
use uh to be carried out however the the
operators see fit uh for this particular
building
um
i've got
nothing to add other than um
to say that again the late papers update
the recommendation to
let us just look at the section 106
agreement uh prior to the issuing of a
decision on your behalf if you seek to
approve it
just to ensure that that
it either needs to be varied or
allows this to take place
and just to confirm that in the
recommendation the conditions that refer
to use
and external plant as well just to
ensure there is no external plant um it
follows the environmental health advice
on page 348
so making sure that's all clear and
that's the recommendation thank you
councillor byrne
yeah thank you um
chairman um
if i read this correctly uh the the
present use was um
to
allow artists in residence accommodation
i presume that means um visiting
artists in other words not necessarily
permanently on site
um
is there any other residential component
in wingfield barnes that would still
allow for
um
accommodation of
artists in residence or is this the only
one
i'm sorry i'm afraid i don't know
i don't know if there is
i think i think it'd be unlikely there
it is but i don't
but i don't think there is there is oh
thank you
um
sorry thank you for you know more about
that yeah just just if i step in there
yes this is the only and it is quite
unusual it is the only accommodation
that is
was created as for artists in residence
there is no other within the complex
do any other members have any other
questions
and i think this is the only
facility for
visiting artists residents in
mid-sephora
i don't think there's any other
obviously visiting artists can use
holiday accommodation that may be
scattered throughout the district as
well but um i would also point out that
we have already previously approved
essentially the removal of this for a
day
nursery which is implementable
at this time
this proposal before you essentially
looks to expand upon that to provide a
more flexible use
for this building however they see fit
to use it
any other questions from members
okay
well just so i can understand what this
means
the same
the same accommodation is used currently
or can be used currently for as a day
nursery yeah
is that is that what you just said
yes so there's an outstanding
application approved on this site to
allow from the occasional residential
use to a day nursery
but instead of implementing that we are
looking at
a wider range of uses which is what's
proposed
which is set out
in page 348
to allow not just potentially a day
nursery if they wish to use this
building as a day nursery but also
professional services and financial
services or office functions and so they
have a choice of what they put this
building forward as
obviously
they may choose not to implement any of
that and continue to use it for
occasional visitors to stay over but
i'm guessing there is not so much demand
for that at the moment so they are
looking at alternative uses of the
building
um but
was i correct
when i heard you say um
that instead of implementing
implementing the day nursery
um change abuse
that does that suggest that um
it's not yet implemented or it hasn't
the need for it hasn't arisen
it has not been implemented that this
proposal would integrate the day nursery
as an option
so
with with this proposal they could go
ahead with a day nursery if they wish to
but they also have a choice of going
ahead with an office use or other
financial services
so they are getting a permission that
allows them to do more than the
permission they got a couple of years
ago that just says day nursery
okay but it would remove the ability to
use it as accommodation i if they
implement it yes
okay thank you very much
um well we don't have an objective
supporter or agent but we do have a
comment from the ward member coach
lavinia hadingham which i will ask the
governor's officer to read once again
please thank you
thank you chair it's the exact same
comment as the previous one on this
members want to hear it specifically
again i will
leave it at that
i will now open up the item for debate
council stringer
uh
yeah i declared the interest earlier
about
being involved with another arts venue
equally i'm probably one of the only
people here that's actually been in this
building when it's been used for the
residential purpose i interviewed a folk
singer in here
and what was interesting i was speaking
to her then member of the wingfield
board about this building to say you
have this building purely to
you know
house an artist while they're having a
performance here
and they said yes
we do and it cost us a fortune so what
they have to do is maintain this
building and it was being used probably
five or six evenings a year
uh which seemed
an awful stretch on resources just
purely for that function
uh and it hadn't been used i think we
need to be so careful of the term artist
in residence
rarely does an artist in resident
reside in the place their artist in
residency for
a number of organizations have an artist
in residence that that aren't in
resident in that building
they live elsewhere but they are called
an artist in residence
i i can see why
this would need to want to be changed
purely because often now if artists come
to play or
do whatever they do they either
as part of their deal get a bed and
breakfast or one of the volunteers or in
the organization house them while
they're here uh and it makes the whole
thing more more efficient in terms of uh
what it costs uh so i personally again
don't have a huge issue with this and
see it part of a potential
diversification
the other issue about this this
residence accommodation here it was it
was also couldn't be made dda compliant
uh because it
the bed facilities were up up almost
allowed up to get to them so they
couldn't be dda compliant so um yeah i i
i don't have a huge issue with this i
would
gladly move approval thank you chuck
stringer councillor cook please
taking the the proposal uh what this is
essentially doing is to give the
organization there
uh
the the maximum opportunity of
generating uh revenue
to support arts activity on
on the site
uh and they've been through some uh
difficult times in the past um where
actually the prospect of there be no
arts activities been been a reality so
i'm supportive of anything that
increases
the ability of this uh of of the team
there to continue i i mean i would point
out that this is probably an occasion
where the provision of
accommodation as council stringer said
is far more costly
this is about the most expensive way of
meeting the need i mean just across the
road
is the
for instance the delipole arms and i'm
sure
other pubs are available by the way but
um
that i'm sure it'd be possible to come
to some arrangement there where that to
be needed in the future but for me this
is uh
a very straightforward and sensible
proposal uh that we ought to support
thank you does anybody other member wish
to speak
counselor warboys please
i i don't really wish to get into an
argument about what an artist in
residence does or whether he wants to
live on site or work on site
and
take advantage of the context of the
exhibition space and be accessible to
members of the public all these things
an artist of residents can do and
actually live and work on the site
um
he may just visit the site and stay in
the pub opposite and work in the garden
as well
um
and perhaps
the fact that the building hasn't been
used as an artistry in residence site is
it
may reflect on the fact that there is an
artist in residence programme but that
goes beyond the planning matters
i think my
i don't feel i can support this i think
we are diminishing
um a public asset um
i do remember
when this
wingfield arts was set up it was
an idealistic
approach yes it was supported by the
arts council
and for many years it worked very well
as a very
as a premier
site for for the arts
and but since the arts council withdrew
which supported us
it has um
it has changed
um
[Music]
i think we're losing a site that's got
potential
for future development
then it's very close to i i is growing
as a community and i think there may
well be
future
needs i do
appreciate that the current
um climate may
think that the sort of use of office the
buildings for office space and rented
out as office space
may bring an alternative income
stream in
but the other side of the coin is the
arts
have always needed support they don't
just happen they're not necessarily
immediately commercially
uh viable they are there as um
as an investment in the community if you
like so i i don't think i can
support this
or wait does any other member wish to
speak
okay thank you very much indeed for that
well um i've listened to the debate and
i totally respect all the comments that
they're made by members but um i tend to
agree that uh with certainly the
clarification we've received from
council stringer
these venues are probably quite
difficult to um you need to get income
in etcetera so i am therefore in favor
of this particular development and i
will be voting for it so therefore i
would no like to well the actual
recommendation is as we had for the
previous application
in which case i will ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
please thank you
thank you chair so the recommendation
now reads the application dc 21
02116 be approved as detailed in the
updated officer recommendation
which includes the points as detailed in
the table papers which apply to both
so i will now start the vote for members
and i will also ask
councillor david byrne can i take your
vote verbally please
i'm against against thank you
[Applause]
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is six votes four and
two against so that is carrick thank you
very much indeed well um thank you
everybody that's the end of this morning
session we have two applications to
consider this afternoon and we will
resume in the chamber at 1400 hours so
thank you very much indeed for your time
this morning
right
good afternoon everybody welcome to this
meeting of the development control b
committee my name is councillor dave
muller and i'll be chairing the meeting
this afternoon
i would no like to ask the governance
officer to remind you of some domestic
arrangements
thank you
thank you chair obviously um members
will hear this this morning but this is
the benefit of everyone who's joined us
this afternoon
um so please ensure that you maintain
social distancing from all other persons
whilst in the chamber and in the
communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face
covering at all times unless you are
sitting down or if you are exempt from
doing so and that you use the hand
sanitizer and wipes provided
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use and please do
not interrupt other speakers or hold
separate conversation whilst others are
speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave and
please ensure that your mobile phones
are on silent or switched off
finally we'll be using e-voting for this
meeting on modern.gov app
so fire safety regulations are that when
evacuating the building please leave the
building immediately via the fire exits
and make your way to the assembly point
which is on ipswich town football club
ipswich town football club's training
pitch
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exits at each end of the floor do
not enter the atrium the ground floor
area and the walkways
if you are in the atrium at the time of
the alarm follow the size of the nearest
fire exit use the stairs not the lifts
and please do not re-enter the
building until you are told it is safe
to do so
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed and by entering this meeting as a
speaker you're also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not not lawfully excluded
thank you chair
thank you
i will now invite the case officer uh
john pakeman g to introduce the
application to the committee excuse me
hi as i couldn't make the earlier
meeting can i just declare a pecuniary
interest in this item i am a neighbour
so i think it's important that that's
clear from the outset
please thank you chair and just to carry
on from that um i would like to inform
members and we'll be recording the moves
that council hicks does have a
dispensation from the proper officer um
to take part um in this meeting as the
board member and this has been sorted
this uh and is available to view um this
is in line with the localism act 2011
under part 1 chapter 7 section 33 and
can be described under
part c which considers the granting the
dispensation is in the interest of
persons living within the authorities
area as such there will also be attached
to council hicks register of interest um
as is standard procedure if there is any
questions here i'm more than happy to
therefore after i've spoken i'll leave
the chamber so i don't take part or hear
any of the debates by members
mr payton g would you like to introduce
the application
all please
thank you
so this is a full uh planning
application for the demolition of the
existing agricultural barn and direction
of a one and a half story dwelling house
essentially two-story if we put it
another way um
change of use uh from agricultural land
to c3 dwelling house
uh let's start with
ugly the aerials so
that's very helpful let's try the next
one
that's the site uh right at the top
there um so we've come out quite a ways
because it's uh fairly uh
it's countryside so it's trying to get
your bearings so that's where the site
is
if we close up to that the barn in the
middle of the uh aerial there is the the
barn in question
and hopefully we get a bit closer that's
the bar
put it into context that's the site with
the barn
and that's the location plan
so the proposal this situation in open
countryside as you just saw the
character of the site is entirely rural
there is no immediate neighbours to the
site the site is not part of any
particular
land designations and it's not close in
our opinion to uh heritage assets the
nearest um grade two listed building is
known as grow farm which is 120 meters
according to the case officer notes from
the site which is the one to the south
so if i go on to the constraints the
list of building is going to swap
around
that one there
as to the self
the green dotted lines are public rights
away they could be by the ways it just
comes up as rights of way uh footpaths
available
um
so there's no other constraints on the
site itself and of course those public
rights away aren't directly related to
the site either
this is the current building as you just
saw in the aerial photographs
and the proposal
is to replace that
with the building as shown on this block
plan essentially the outline of the
current building
is that and this is essentially built
within that
footprint
so here we are replacing the existing
barn uh we're they what we refer to as a
modest new dwelling um
with it does it although increase while
it's slightly smaller in terms of floor
area and
footprint it is slightly higher by two
and a half meters
in terms of height
but it is a smaller footprint
representing a reduction of 32 i say 34
square meters
these are the elevations
of the new proposal it's a
more modern contemporary design
notes
and if we take the sections as well
and we have some photographs provided by
the coast officer
of the existing building in this setting
that's of the
agricultural building and it's setting
that's it
i'll leave that on the block plan for
now
so
a little bit of an explanation i think
needed here let's start with the
principle of development um
this
is a new dwelling in the countryside um
it's not a reuse of a building it's not
for agricultural purpose it's not
affordable it's not subdivision of an
existing garden or house it's not
previously developed learned and so
under
the nppf and the current local plan it
could be argued to be not supported in
policy terms at the moment
instead is the material consideration of
what we officers like to call the
fallback
under class q this is permitted
development
you have the government changed this a
couple of years ago
to allow the change of use of virtually
any building in the countryside
such as this to become a dwelling if it
was an agricultural use before now there
is criteria there but essentially this
can become dwelling under permitted
development and sometimes it could be
more than one dwelling
uh in this case
that has been applied and granted as a
prior approval notification and so it
has already established that this could
be this existing bomb building can
become a dwelling
um
now
when you consider
the
criteria for committed development
rights that the new procedure allows for
a couple years ago
essentially sustainability
is not a criteria of that provision
we are expressly not allowed to use
sustainability as a reason to refuse
permitted development rights that have
been granted by class q
so
there are criteria that does apply
highways biodiversity and flooding
and but as long as of course you're not
allowed to extend the existing building
so you can't make it bigger
um but essentially this building has
already passed all of that criteria and
has been given prior approval to be a
dwelling so
that is the material consideration that
this has already given given that
consent
so for the purposes of the planning
application before us now we have the
principle of this being approved as a
dwelling as a significant material
consideration
appeals
have upheld this approach and we now
have many approvals in the district and
the country for replacement of such
buildings with new dwellings instead
so once class q is established
we you you have the
establishment of the principle of
residential use and then you come in
potentially with a replacement
now in mid-suffolk we have upheld the
idea that any such approach on that
basis should not enlarge the building
that was there
and we've maintained good practice in
that respect
and this one doesn't this doesn't
enlarge what's there in the context of
that judgment
um
anything so anything that does come
along that's bigger than what was there
before we then feel that the
sustainability argument can engage
but in this case we don't feel that's
appropriate because it's not got bigger
now i appreciate the class q
consideration maybe a new
um
element for consideration for some
members and hopefully
that explains it normally something of
this nature less than ten houses uh
would be a delegated matter and i
suspect this doesn't come up that often
uh with members
if you need any more information on
class q i will try and answer the best i
can
in terms of the current building um
proposal before us it would have some
visibility within the public realm
um
along the roads of uh south hold road
and horror mode
um but due to the modest scale and
appearance the presence of trees along
the two roads and even with the height
increase compared to the existing
is not considered intrusive to the
landscape to warrant refusal the design
is more contemporary
however it maintains in our opinion as
officers a rural style and character and
is not considered to appear offensive or
harmful to the visual visual loca
amenity of the locality
in terms of heritage impact our heritage
team were consulted as part of the
process and do not have an objection in
respect of nearby heritage assets that
have been recognized and in conclusion
we do not see that there is any harm to
residential amenity or access and on
balance the proposal is considered to be
one to approve
based on the material considerations of
the previous class queue
i will add that the recommendation
before members in their papers there is
one condition missing and i would like
to add that which is the removal of
permitted development rights for
extensions and alterations
so i would like to add that to the
recommendation before members and the
recommendation is one of approval
thank you
thanks
thanks very much uh chat and as um
uh as peyton g has uh kind of
anticipated this category
q and that is is uh
is is a newish uh idea uh
for for for me
um
what i wanted to ask you referred to
prior approval
i wondered whether
um
that reflects the giving of granting a
prior approval
reflects a judgment made by the officers
concerned
if they are making a judgment as opposed
to really having no choice
uh be
because of the nature of the
of the thing but if there is a judgment
there made by officers does that limit
effectively limit the discretion of this
committee
this application before you is an
application in its own right so let's
set that aside for a second
the
application has been approved at class q
so what we do is we start with pete
the government decided that change of
use of bonds such as this in the
countryside two dwellings is permitted
development
and then when they said decided that
they said right it's permitted
development but there is a process you
have to go through which is called prior
approval so you have to send a prior
approval application to the local
planning authority for them to look at
and
in the judgment of that prior approval
application we have a criteria to judge
that application
sustainability was expressly taken out
as a criteria for us to judge
um by the government um
ultimately they are promoting the reuse
of redundant buildings in the
countryside that is the idea behind it
um a number of the criterias remain
highway impact and safety uh flood uh
biodiversity inter interests and that
and others they but it's limited than if
it was a normal planning application
there is also criteria what qualifies as
a building that can go through this
prior approval process
the building must have been used large
i'm not going to go for all of them but
it must have gone through it must have
been an agricultural use previously um
it can't be a listed building uh it
cannot it can't be extended and it also
has to stand up so essentially it's not
a case of it collapses it has to prove
that you can
convert it that said
in some appeal decisions the building is
literally stripped down to girders and
that's still considered to be okay
but this is a case law argument more
than anything else in terms of the
judgment of when
is something structurally sound
so we have to go through that process
and in this case we have gone through
that process and we have granted the
prior approval to allow this building as
it stands to be converted into a
dwelling
so that can happen
whenever they wish to get started with
that
ultimately
that then stands as a material
consideration
for the dealing with this planning
application
okay so we already know that a house can
be here
it can be the conversion of what's
already there on the ground or they
knock it down and we accept this
effectively revised proposal if you like
but the process is a slightly different
one is obviously a prior approval
process that gets them to that stage
this is a planning application that
should be determined in its on its own
merits
but thanks to various case law appeals
across the country and including
our practice here
there has
been the acceptance
that
once you've got the prior approval
you've essentially got the principle of
residential use
and so the planning application needs to
bear that in mind and that's what we've
done here
yeah i just want to watch some
clarification
uh
i think you said during the presentation
that the proposal is
two and a half meters taller than the
original building
yet it is
no bigger
well
i struggle
surely height is part of its he's a
mangled mango exchange bigness i i don't
get how if it's taller how it's not
bigger than the original proposal it is
great it is is it a bigger in terms of
height is a bigger building by
by two meters i think the kosovo's notes
were i can measure it if you like
but
obviously compared one to the end to the
other this is taller we know that
we've taken the stance because prior
approval allows you to convert a
building
to a certain floor area
to become a house so that's where the pd
comes in
when we deal with a planning application
what we don't want what we decided as
officers a couple of years ago is we
don't need to suddenly see
small
little barns suddenly becoming seven
bedroom mansions because they go from
one floor space to
x floor space
so we said well actually
they have permitted development
essentially for a certain floor space
we should limit it to that and anything
that exceeds that floor space
we then feel that it is justifiable to
start to argue the sustainability
argument once more we can't argue it
with the floor space as existing because
the prior approval process
takes us out of the equation for that
but if anything more
we believe we can justifiably say this
is not in the spirit of the fire
approval process that the government set
up
so
when we look at these if they are
similar or smaller in floor space as
they come along as replacements
essentially we have found that to be
a good practice there is nothing in law
to say it can't be bigger
but
we've established that in this council
as a as a guiding principle to say that
we shouldn't be looking at the extension
of what prior approval allows as floor
level the floor space
does that make
sense yeah but it just begs another
question
you said that there was a certain amount
of permit development for floor area
uh it didn't
it so i won't say limits the floor but
constraints for it so within that
permitted development then there's no
constraint on height because using the
same logic i'm thinking you could build
a building now that's four meters square
but but 80 meters tall and it would
still be permitted
this is the planning judgment at this
point
ultimately um
the prior approval deals with the
building as existing
and that includes height width depth the
whole lot
this is
in his own judgment a new dwelling
does the height
cause harm to the locality in terms of
its rural
you know
character harm and so on if you feel the
height of this proposal
is detrimental
and to the point where we think we could
warrant refusal that is a judgment for
you to make we're saying yes there is an
increase in height we don't think it's
by much that makes a big difference in
terms of this locality
you may feel differently obviously as
members but your officer opinion is we
don't think we could park a refusal on
that issue solely and we don't think we
need to go further down that road
okay
any questions
case delayer than case
just
slightly confused really the application
is considered controversial
but the
the original
um
approval
should that not have been considered
controversial as well
the other
wonderful
addition to the procedure of bio
approvals is if we don't deal within a
certain time frame they get approval by
default
so therefore we don't have that
mechanism in place to come to committee
because by the time it got to committee
it would have already been approved so
we can't deem something to be
controversial with respect to prior
approvals or well it's very impractical
to do so um in respect to this this is a
planning application so we have
we don't have an automatic approval to
worry about we are just dealing with
this until we dealt with it
um and of course in this case
the word controversial is simply down to
um the point about the surrounding
ownership of this site um conscious in
the public interest that there are
public members
that are
part of our we know uh a part of this it
was felt that it's better to have this
transparent and open conversation about
this application uh rather than it be a
delegated decision so the word
controversy isn't perhaps the right word
but it's the word that says that that is
the ability of the chief planning
officer to push this to committee to
ensure this is all above board and very
clear to the public what's going on
without hiding behind anything or
appearing to hide behind anything
does that help
counselor google please
thanks just
the
question i was going to ask larry
addressed by cancer stringer's
supplementary question
it's about the height
issue again and i'm i'm trying to that
what lies at the back of this is trying
to understand the discussion that we
have as a
as a committee
so so when the prior approval was given
uh was that given knowing the proposed
height the development
so the prior approval was based on the
existing building only the idea that
that was convertible in its own
shape size height as existing so there
was no expansion to that building um
considered because that would fail the
criteria of prior approval
i i think i take the computer i
understand where you're coming from
we we as officers have taken the point
about floor space should we have also
taken the point about height um
i don't know but i think we we would
struggle to find
the harm
in the judgment of height
and then that's a planning judgment i'm
afraid i'm probably not making myself
very clear the trouble here is this is a
situation that's been developed out of
case law
after the event of the the setting up of
the prior approval and
we've made a planning judgment that
we'll do we'll seek to defend ourselves
over the floor area
and
but the the appeals that we've seen have
allowed very different designs to come
forward to the original barn that was
there in the first place right
i mean free experience of these
committees but very very often the
height of the building is is
seems more of a factor in terms of
impact on landscape and surrounding than
the necessary floor area so it just
seems odd to me that in considering
prior approval
um subject to the constraints
of the judgment we're able to make it
just seems seems off but to
to so if there is scope to do that and
maybe that is something that we should
consider but just to be clear therefore
when taking up
in the committee making a judgment about
this application it is entirely
legitimate for us to consider the impact
of the proposed height of the building
yes um your your judgment is does the
des well actually your judgment's the
whole thing
the external appearance of the building
uh the height its
width depth so on if you feel as
members it would be harmful to amenity
of residents to the list of building to
the landscape quality of this particular
location and you have a consideration
about that in your debate you can if you
wish to refuse it on those base on that
basis
the prior approval is only one
consideration
we feel as officers it's a significant
one because it establishes the principle
of
in our view of residential use of this
site um but where you go i will help you
as need be uh as the debate progresses
if i made sherman so to avoid any pos to
avoid any possible doubt in me as a
legal adviser as much as anyone else the
when we talk about the fallback position
planning that traditionally is
understood as what the applicant could
do tomorrow if we said no this afternoon
and the applicant didn't want to appeal
that that is that your understanding as
well mr peyton g
yes so if we refute so let's go down the
scenario if members to refuse this
application today there is nothing
stopping them going ahead and converting
the existing building on site tomorrow
as a residential house they've already
got approval to do that
so
in terms of my position if i had to go
to an appeal inspector and say why did i
refuse this application given the fact
that they convert the existing building
under permitted development essentially
i would need sufficient unders you know
ground i need ground
to
have a decent go arguing and defending
your position so
we feel that this is
not that case
the actual design in the office of view
is acceptable
it's different to what's there but we
don't think it's harmful to warrant
refusal that is the position and our
recommendation to you to accept what
they can do as the fallback position and
it and look at this
the alternative proposal favorably that
is our recommendation for for four
members but the fallback is
as my colleague says
if we did refuse this they could go
ahead and
put residential use here anyway um
equally if we did refuse this they can
get an appeal just decision you know
they always have that option
and if if i may chair again the the
fallback position precisely involves the
um
reliance on implementation of the prior
approval which would result in a
building off
no higher than the existing barn yes
and with the same dimensions and scale
yeah so the full back position though is
the existing building no higher no wider
no bigger
are there any more questions for our
members
no
okay i would no like to move on to the
public speakers and i would like to
invite mr hamling and mrs gibson harry's
please from the parish council uh you
have three minutes thank you
thank you very much chairman
um yes i'm chairman of horror nethington
parish council
we as a whole parish council have been
down to look at the site on two
occasions
um we've spoken to both parties parties
that are um proposing and those that are
objecting and we did at some stage
um uh on the recommendation of the
parish council asked the two parties to
get together to talk about the bits that
they felt uh were uh unacceptable to
them uh and how that could be resolved
we we hoped that that had been the case
but presumably it hasn't
we're a small village
um we're between i and stradbroke so
we're between two larger villages
we do encourage people to come and and
live in haram uh it would help us
towards keeping our shop getting our
bus reinstated and so forth we do need
more people coming to live in the
village
that would make us more sustainable
we feel
that the applicant has done everything
possible to make this ex this particular
application acceptable
as a parish council we've got
various people on our parish council
builders and
people of all walks of life we've looked
at it from every angle and we would be
very happy to see this building go ahead
we do understand that there are some
uh reservations about heights presumably
um this is the first time that i've
heard the height brought up i have to
say
but if that's so presumably it could be
worked on but i don't want to see two
really nice people that have tried their
very best to come and build and live in
haram
made unwelcome and unsatisfied by their
efforts to come and join us i uh haram
and ethington parish council would like
to add their um stump to the fact that
we approve this application thank you
chairman
any questions for the
ward member please
or rather the
parish council sorry
none
okay thank you very much i'd like to now
move on to the applicant agent mr gary
and mr hughes
i'll just wait for this to um
okay yep you have three minutes
yes if you can press the button please
[Applause]
okay okay it's once in lifetime
opportunity for us to build our own home
so we wanted to ensure that it was the
best designed most sustainable home we
could achieve fitting lightly in its
landscape so we engage with an
award-winning winning local architect
good afternoon
um
we've taken great effort um with the
design of the house that sits well in
its rural surroundings
we've developed a scheme in close
consultation with the planning
department over the last six months
the scale of the building is smaller
than the class q approval and the
additional half story allows a smaller
footprint to incorporate a garage and
keep the domestic paraphernalia
including cars behind the house away
from the meadow
the additional height is modest we've
talked about that a lot and
we don't believe it would detract from
our neighbours who are more than 120
metres away
the pros building materials draw on the
features of the existing barn the gray
weather timber cloudy and large windows
in the east elevation mirror the
openings of the existing barn
dividing the house into two volumes of
the single story link reduces the
overall visual impact of the building
compared with the existing monoblock
form
and allows greater opportunity for
natural lighting and a narrower
footprint
the building is an area of
countryside scattered with homes and
agricultural buildings which also build
light across fields and through
hedgerows our proposal and the approved
class q design will create light but we
will minimize this with shrouded light
fittings
sustainable design is important to us as
a practice and with jason kirsten we've
developed a scheme that can meet the
future home standard
we've summarized some of the proposed
measures on table paper three which has
been circulated i believe
care has also been taken with consider
considering the landscaping the plan
includes planting more than 50 trees
along with traditional suffolk hedging
to boundaries
the garden coach list is drawn as 0.6 of
an acre retaining 90 of the meadow
in agricultural use
we agree with the planning office's
conclusion that our design is an
aesthetic improvement on the class q
approval and would not impact upon
neighbouring residential amenities
um we we consulted with neighbours early
on to understand their concerns we tried
to accommodate these concerns and
engaged in a very constructive pre-op
process with the planning department
prior to submitting our application we
presented our plans on site to our
neighbours and later the parish council
who were very supportive and like the
new design better than the improved
class q scheme we're really very
grateful of the support parish council
thank you very much do you have any
questions for the app for the applicant
stroke agent at all from memphis
council stringer piece
sorry just want to clarify
you described it as a modest increase in
height
i've calculated it at 2.525 meters let
me just clarify that yes
yes that's correct we don't need to
expand or not
okay so it it allows us to have not a
full two story so at the eaves it's low
height it's about 1.5 meters but it
allows us to then compress the footprint
because we were concerned that the
paraphernalia of cars and things like
that which would be seen across the
field can then be tucked between our the
development and the road and the
entrance can be on that side as well so
so the view of the building from across
the field
will be
unencumbered by
any um
paraphernalia which i know that is often
of concern so that's one of the prime
movers for changing the form of the
building it also allows us to have a
form which is more house-like and less
bond-like in terms of a low-pitched roof
which we have at the moment
thank you very much do we have any more
questions council of the war boys then
counselor melon please
uh could you just go through the um
the existing barn is sort of um
vertical
uh wooden cladding yeah and a corrugated
roof yes and the finishes on your
proposed building are going to be
they're going to be it's a it's a
standing seam zinc roof there's a metal
roof
and then it has vertical cladding on the
facades and we've split the cutting into
two types of cladding to mirror the
previous um split in the clouding of the
existing building
which is the horizontal line so there
are two forms of timber cladding just
with slightly different treatment to um
emphasize the horizontality of it
thank you
thank you melon please thank you chad
can you just give me a bit more detail
on the on the um
the measures you said
because i don't think we have them in
the bundle the heating and the
environmental measures you you briefly
touched on
i have members seen i circulated
uh
it was tabled and attached to the report
has that been
is that i'm not sure whether that's been
circulated is that
oh okay
so
um
so we as a practice we um
are quite experienced in the use of
ground source heat pumps and sustainable
heating um
and
we
have intended to use that with low
surface temperature heating is a very
efficient way of heating a dwelling um
are in terms of selection materials
we're looking at materials which are
also sustainable timber zinc has a very
long life and also can be recycled
um
we intend to use in terms of thermal
element
timber frame design which can be which
is very thermally efficient and also
renewable
um
this will be an airtight building so
that there's no heat loss through
through the fabric of the building and
we will lose mechanical heat recovery to
uh make the best use of the heat that we
have to put into it so it's not expelled
triple glazing yes triple gazing
very
much do we have any more questions
counselors please
okay thank you mr chairman
um just mention of the height being
another 2.5 meters now i work out to be
something over eight feet
and
the
windows
on the plan that we have before us are
much more numerous
than previously does this not lead
in the applicant's opinion would i not
accept that this will generate more
light pollution into the surrounding
countryside
well i think
the
approval is already been made for a
dwelling on the site
and
it's not being raised by
our discussions with the planning
department that the scale of the windows
we propose which are not abnormal for a
modern dwelling
[Music]
to suggest that we should curtail them
so
we haven't had any input from the
planning department in that regard
i think the external lighting that we
would incorporate which
would be
shrouded to prevent glare
but
do you have anything yeah and the
existing class q
the one that we've got permission for is
very very small windows it actually
means that during the day we'll have to
have the lights on more so not only is
it not very energy efficient
having those lights on it also mean yeah
there's going to be more light
through through those windows because we
have the lights on more often with the
larger windows it means we've got
greater natural lighting we don't need
the lights on us and nearly as much
yes
that can easily be solved by curtains
you know people have curtains and so on
so you know we can have that also
because it's in two blocks actually
there's two of us we're going to end up
living in an evening in a much smaller
footprint than the existing class queue
the classic queue is incredibly open
plan
which means that light in one area of
the house will be switched on and will
doesn't matter which window it will come
out of those other windows as well
by moving actually into one of the one
part of the house
you know that's actually reduced it so
yes there are more windows but actually
of an evening we'll be living in half
the house so actually it's less windows
thank you
do we have any more questions
no
okay thank you very much
mr mcgarry and mr hughes thank you i
will now ask the ward member counselor
matthew hicks to speak thanks thanks
very much mr chairman um and just to be
absolutely clear i live in the immediate
property the old directory which is on
your map
and
i have declared that interest at every
parish council meeting as well and just
to be absolutely clear now
and also the reason i'm really glad it's
come to committee is between the section
q and today there was another
application which was withdrawn which
showed my land under their ownership
because we'd agree to sell it but
obviously that's
uh
that will
we don't know what we'll do but we'll
sort something out after today so i just
want to be absolutely transparent that i
was in the process of selling some land
to the applicant in this process
um
so i guess i'm in a very difficult
position because i'm the ward member i
live next door i've got uh i've got
neighbors and my partner who have put in
uh views on this and i'm just going to
touch on their views are then going to
touch on the parish council's views and
then i'll leave i'm not going to express
a personal view and i think it's very
important i do that so i think from the
objectors point of view there are three
points just for the committee to
consider it's it's it's really a
question of how important do you uh
value them or not um the first thing i
guess is um around the
impact on the immunity uh going from 11
windows to 10 v lux windows 17 lower
windows and two top and bottom windows
are going from 11 to 29 windows and the
impact that has on the wildlife is what
some of the neighbors have put in
their written representations which
you've seen
the section q issue is interesting
section q's established the principal
development's absolutely established um
the house could be built it's already
there i guess the question is and and
this is where the uh
in the conclusion papers on 9.2 the full
back position
does this present an aesthetic
improvement and i guess that is the
question on the fallback the fullback
position is that what's coming forward
provides a betterment
so is this a betterment or is it not a
betterment and again i think that's
something for you to probably consider
um
the impact on the wildlife i think is
the third point so
we've talked about obviously the
landscape and character but the actual
impact on the wildlife by having the
light pollution in the evening is that
something that needs to be considered um
i understand that the neighbor the
coalnets who live and grow farm have
written to members around the bats and
the impact on them
i'm afraid i'm no expert in that and i
noticed in the papers the ecology have
not commented to that but obviously
that's what these guys as the neighbors
think
um so i think those are probably the
three key points the principle of
development is absolutely established uh
the question is is this a betterment or
not i absolutely agree with the parish
council
it's a great shame that there wasn't an
opportunity the applicant did present
this application to the neighbors but
they presented it they didn't discuss it
and i agree absolutely the parish
council what we always say at this
committee and what we always say at
parish council meetings is get together
see how you can reach a compromise and
walk away so everyone's happy
unfortunately that didn't happen in this
application so i totally support the
parish council's view that actually
that's the best solution for everyone if
that could be achieved i think it'd be a
much better outcome uh than having to
you know go through this difficulty
today but we are where we are so that's
all from me
thank you counselor hicks do we have any
questions for the award member piece
counselor
burn um thank you chairman
um
can i just ask you for
for my information
where the old rectory is
relevant to relative to this uh this
particular site is it is it is it to the
north
yes
it is i mean it is i we are in the land
right next to the so the site was split
into half the land we bought half the
land they bought so they were up here
yes and the land all the way around
there as well this yeah
yeah yeah thank you
do we have any more questions counselor
melon please
yes thank you chad it's just a
clarification on the number of velux
window because i can only see
i think three in the roof
but i think you mentioned a higher
number sorry the number of
windows
uh i'm told uh and i'm i i'm told that
there are
uh
uh hold on let me read it ten window v
lux winners on the upper floor so a
combination on the upper floor
i thought i thought of a pertinent
question to the applicant that just
suddenly dropped in my am i allowed to
ask that it's a technical question
yeah
the under the class queue
to have converted that building to
residential would the
foundations need underpinning
no um part of the process of class q is
that you have to demonstrate the
existing building is
um available
for for conversions that's right
likewise
no is no is sufficient
the second part of that question is will
this new building need
new footings
the yes it would need new footings
the class q could also have more windows
looking at the drawing it looks like
there are only three v-lux windows
rather than 11 so i think we just got to
be clear on how many windows there are
clarify the number of windows please
thank you dv lux is in the roof thank
you very much
will now open the um
application to debate who would like to
start the debate please
counselor stringer
yeah
thank you chair
this one is a i think a delicately
balanced one uh
and and it all rides on
an awful lot of uh
not unknowns but things that are that
can form judgment
what's what's not in judgment is this is
not a sustainable location as it were
for mass housing i think we all agree
read that so so anything that limits the
environmental impact of introducing a
dwelling here is to be
accepted and encouraged
one of the big issues i have though is
the height
2.5 meters plus is technically another
story
irrespective of shrinking the footprint
two and a half meters is a normal
living floor height
uh
in in an incredibly rural location
and then putting glazing at such a high
is also now introducing all sorts of
elements irrespective of what could be
done
the the other issue i have uh having
lived with
a minimal amount of glass at height if
you put large expanses of glass at
height you also kill an awful lot of
birds because they literally fly
straight into them
and or that can be tackled using
something called clarification which
certainly can be done
part of it also
i get the point that a modern fabric
can minimize not eliminate heat loss it
can minimize heat loss which this is
intending to do but of course to achieve
that we now have to have to bring this
forward a whole new series of concrete
footings underneath it to support the
structure
with all the resultant emissions to to
make that happen
uh
and and and so
and i think we can't get away from the
case well the case law does allow for a
replacement dwelling of a class q i
frankly think that's
madness because if you set a series of
criteria that you have to convert what's
there and it has to be convertible and
then when you've achieved that you say
we'll scrap that you can have almost
anything i think is is not right
uh but i think in this case i i i think
i think 2.5 meters in an ultra rural
position like this
as well as needing new structure
underneath is in environmental terms
just that step too far so i think on
balance i i can't support the officer's
recommendation
thank you very much counter stringer do
any other members wish to
make a
comment
counselor
yes um
yeah i agree with cancer strength is
balanced i think i'm
i do note the concerns about the height
and the increased number of windows um
but
looking at the actual building that's
proposed i it is an improvement from a
design point of view
and um
within the national planning framework i
i i don't think it's quite false into
that
there is a
[Music]
comment about outstanding design being
allowed
in isolated rural settings now i'm not
sure this is quite outstanding but it is
an improvement in design terms it is
higher yes um
would it be i've just pulled up the
previous i didn't do my homework
probably i should have looked last night
um i've just looked at the section q is
it an improvement as a living space over
the open plan
uh monolith shape i i think yes i think
you've got a much more
interesting
interior
and probably from an environment point
of view
more energy efficient
um
[Music]
it
does re
address the detailing
on the existing building uh it just
repeat that
i think within the
papers there's guidance about light
levels
from place services which i think
probably should make a condition that
we've got this
wildlife sensitive lighting scheme
though the applicant has actually sort
of already
put forward that they're very sensitive
to that already
um
so
and again looking at the setting from
the road you've got a monolithic shape
quite low which is
virtually screened by existing trees uh
this won't come a public just
um two meters tape so that's sort of
what 10
11 feet
um
i think it is an improvement in design
um and a better building for people to
live in
um
[Music]
so i'm
tending to come down in favor of the
design
thank you councillor warboys councillor
norris then councillor byrd
thank you uh like uh councillor springer
i have
quite a number of reservations about
what is proposed i mean to me this
appears to be quite a dominant structure
in an isolated position i question why
it needs to be another two and a half
meters taller and require obviously
considerable
footings
to support it
to me it is a step too far and i am not
in a position to support this as it
stands but i'll listen to the rest of
the debate thank you
thank you jim
um
i completely agree with the council of
war boys the um
the aesthetic is a
very much an improvement over the
fallback position
and i do believe that the
um
this preoccupation with with height is a
a little bit of a red herring because
um
the fallback height is uh 2.5 meters
less and
of course it is because it's a cattle
barn um
uh i would
i would not like to see
what would effectively be a bungalow on
the on this site it wouldn't it wouldn't
make sense in in this location
so
the height does not seem in any way to
me to be disproportionate to the rest of
the building
[Applause]
yes
there is the potential because of some
very large
windows on um i can't see which on the
east east elevation
east elevation okay
which is
the roadside elevation yes
the other one
overlooking the fields
okay thank you um then that's
less of an objection in that case
because if it was on the east side it
would potentially
interfere with foraging bats etc on the
um
sorry if it was on the west side of
foraging bats
but if it's on the east side that's
less of a concern that doesn't mean to
say that that's what forage on the east
side but
we we did hear from from the applicant
that it will be possible to screen those
windows
during
hours of darkness
and i would um
i don't know i don't know whether we
could possibly condition that they
should have
some form of screening on i doubt it but
if it were possible that i would like to
see it particularly on those windows
there
i don't think the windows
second second story windows
are likely to be of any uh
any concern
they are under the 2.5
meters or substantially under the 2.5
millimeters
so
i can't see
uh anything really to complain about
with this particular application and um
i would be
uh
well i'll leave it for other members to
have their say first if they want to
thank you country burn do we have any
other members who wish to speak
countless
um
i think much of what i'm going to say
has already been said but just trying to
pull things together i do find it
galling that
the government has come up with a system
where one can have a barn one can get
the class q
applied get it converted
and now we're looking at rebuilding you
know if i'd gone for a planning
permission for the
house in front of us it probably
wouldn't have been approved but that's
not what we're looking at today however
upsetting or dis galling i may find that
what we're looking at
is a very well designed building i have
to say
um
i think it is
environmentally sound
it fits its landscape and is the height
an issue
well it's not an issue for the parish
council
so
i take guidance from that and i don't
think that's relevant i think it is
actually a a good design and
i will be supporting this
thank you mayor do we have any other
questions at all counselor melon
yeah thank you chad just a clarification
in the um officer's recommendation we've
got eight bullet points
the fourth one is
biodiversity mitigation in enhancement
enhancement measures
conditions as recommended by ecologists
this this is on page 364 of the bundle
um can i just clarify does that include
um the
the recommendation from play services of
a wildlife sensitive lighting design
scheme
yes
um can i take an opportunity here if i
may um
i i i think i'm going to apologize i
didn't appreciate
that
this sort of application comes along to
officers at a very regular rate
and we haven't i didn't realize this was
essentially the first one of this nature
to have come to members and i think
we've probably not prepared members
sufficiently in that respect to
understand the policy and procedural
context and so i will apologize on that
basis to start with
i will also say though
the process of prior approval
is
i know this is hard to say without being
personal
it is problematic for officers to deal
with because it does limit what they can
impose quite significantly
so
in many respects the planning
application actually allows us the wider
considerations
eg biodiversity
and
sustainability
factors that we cannot
deal with with the prime approval
so with in many respects the conditions
that have actually been placed on your
recommendation
are far in excess of what we could have
done with the prior approval now that's
not to say they can go they could go
back and to deal with approval and build
that that's fine that's an option
but
we are taking the opportunity to at
least apply the policies of the council
to a planning application that we can't
apply to the prior approval i think i'll
leave it there before i ramble too much
but um it is a difficult balance because
of the mechanism that has been imposed
and i do apologize that we didn't give
you a sufficient briefing and perhaps
that's a point for training as well um
that we need to go over that uh more
pragmatically but these things don't
come up to committee because it's
these tend to be only one or two houses
yeah thank you chair um thanks for the
clarification as well and mr patman g um
yeah class q um
i think is very well known in the
farming community i i did attend a
seminar where i saw a number of
landowners rubbing their hands together
um a farming conference a few years ago
and yes we are in a sort of cleft stick
where we have
existing approval and
we have to sort of decide whether this
is an improvement on it um
the height yes is an issue
and obviously the volume
of the this this intended dwelling is
much smaller than the barn
so it's a sort of balance of one against
the other
but um i think there's enough in this
design um for me to
to vote in favor of it thank you chad
thank you coach lemellon
thanks for stringer please yeah just
wanted to just to slightly uh uh
just
re-rehearse
the position i had earlier um just just
to make members aware about
environmental impacts and how
just to try and balance out that
there will be some environmental
efficiency
possibly gained from the new structure
that possibly couldn't be gained from
the previous structure having said that
that was the point of class q
one of the points from the reasons
government rehearsed class queue it was
to push the bounds of what we could do
in terms of environmental efficiency in
and retrofitting in buildings because
that's what we're going to have to do
which is why it's slightly then calling
to then say well once you've passed that
hurdle we can scrap that and start back
from where you were
equally one of the other things that
the agent said there'll be no heat loss
through the the walls there will be some
heat loss through the walls of the
building
actually fractured in the windows it's
0.1
watt per square meter and stuff there is
always heat loss on outside walls and of
course there is a lot more outside walls
in this structure in terms of because it
zigzags into that than the previous
structure but as i said why
the balance for me was the foundations
is because you've got a massive
environmental cost
going to come in approving this because
they're going to have to smash out the
existing foundations to put in brand new
ones and that will be
several cubic metres of concrete which
you wouldn't have to do if you
retrofitted the existing building you've
got which has an existing impact in the
landscape that will not be increased
other than the possible introduction of
glazing and lights but that was also one
of the reasons why this was supposed to
be a challenge to architects to then
see how you can
find solutions to these interesting
buildings that are in our countryside
and there has been some incredible
things done with even grain silos to
bring them up to modern regulations
and turn them into homes so that's a
that's why it's on balance for me i get
the design quite like the design if it
was a new house
inside a settlement boundary or for a
key worker or what have you uh quite
good but the for me it's that radical
height i mean it's more than half the
existing height of the building being
added onto it again i personally think
that is a step too
as well as the environmental impact of
all those brand new foundations that
will have to be put in that you wouldn't
have to if you retrofitted the existing
building that's all i want to say chair
thank you
thanks so much uh
a chair and i think i'm
in the same place as uh as the majority
of the committee
here in terms of
uh
this is a good design i like i like the
design
um
i like it notwithstanding what uh cancer
stringer has said about the impact of
requiring the foundations in other
respects
um the um
environmental credentials of the
building are
seem very considerable i am bothered by
the height light
aspect of this uh
and uh
anything that can be done to mitigate
that i'm not sure i agree with cancer
burn that it's a it's a red herring
herring's red or otherwise not one of
the species likely to be impacted by
that
by the light uh
pollution but i i am i'm i'm bothered by
that perhaps more than
some colleagues but taken in the round
uh and i'm particularly guided by the
views of the parish
council here i i would be happy to
support
this this proposal
it is a good design
and the point that the chair of the
parish councilman about
encouraging
people to move in
to
benefit these you know the future of the
village i i think are is a considerable
point so i'm happy to support this
proposal the officer recommendation
thank you gould
um i'd like to have to say a few words
myself now um
i've listened very been very interested
in all the comments that about to be
made about this particular application
and i was heartened to hear what the
parish council say it is so important
that we support local communities and as
mrs gibson harry's mentioned there is a
shop in the village is very keen that
that is that's of use to the local
residents etc that helps support the
village etcetera i do take the point
about the height of the building
i do believe everything is being done to
make sure it's as energy efficient as
possible bearing in mind we have an ace
to climate change emergency and i do
genuinely believe that it satisfies
paragraph 126 of the national policy
planning framework so i personally will
be supporting this application
thank you so we've had a proposal from
councilman melon do we have a second to
please
counselor war voice thank you
a second uh does anyone else wish to
speak
before we sum up
no okay i will now ask the um area
planning manager to relate the proposal
on the table before we go before we go
to the vote mr peyton g piece just uh so
it was as recommendation on papers with
the addition of removal of pd for
extensions and alterations but there was
a point about windows and a bird impact
is that
part of this now
a scheme to
to deal with that um well i was simply
asking whether it could be
because i think um on those we have two
he's facing large two-story east-facing
windows
there is a a good
a good chance that um
birds may strike those windows and i
think it would be
probably a good idea to try to condition
if it were possible that they they are
obscured in some way during the
hours of darkness
we we have before
put forward a a condition that's
essentially says a scheme to be agreed
uh for the prevention of a bird impact
um
i'll be honest with you though i've not
seen the con what's come back for those
type of conditions but we have done that
before in committee in my in my memory
in the last couple of years so i'm happy
to add that um
but
we would have to explore the applicant
to what extent we can find solutions and
what have we agreed okay
yeah i mean i think whatever can be done
to mitigate bird strike um within
within uh
conditions would be great
yeah just it's technical term i believe
it's called clarification on the glass
it's where you get two pieces of glass
often opposite each other uh
and during daylight a bird will not see
the sheet of the big sheet of glass it
will see the smaller one beyond and it
will come crashing into that this very
building has the same problem all of
that north elevation has had to have
clarification on it to stop the birds
constantly slamming into this building
so equally that happens with glazing at
height that has another piece of glazing
behind it so if that can be addressed uh
with the condition about a scheme of
clarification that doesn't mean verbal
clarification that we clarification in
the class
did i now ask the governor's officer to
go to the electronic vote please
thank you chair so i'll just read out um
what we've got after those
points that have been added to
the recommendation the application dc
2102359 be approved as detailed in the
updated officer recommendation um with
the additional condition of removal of
permitted development rights and a
scheme to be agreed for the prevention
of bird impacts is that
except just to check for mr patron jesus
that
yeah that covers what thank you thank
you
so chair i will now start the vote thank
and if mom's please go to the gov app
and go to the plus sign in the top right
hand corner they'll go on subsection on
voting and attendance
and this will show the vote in progress
in a light blue line
so
um councillor bern can i please take
your vote
verbally
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is six votes four and
two again so the motion is carried thank
you very much indeed
before we move on therefore i recommend
we'll give it 10 minutes so you can be
back in the chamber 20 past three please
just to say before we get started that
um councillor bert sorry
councillor gord has left the meeting so
during the break so we'll not be
returning for the rest of these items
thank you
thank you thank you very much
the final item today is item 8b dc
2103600 gainsborough road car park
gainesville road stone market and i'd
like to invite the case officer alex
scott to introduce the applications the
committee over to you alex please thank
you
yes thank you chairman um yes members as
chairman has just pointed out this is
item 8b application dc 210360
at gainesville road car park
that's adjacent to the mid suffolk uh
leisure center in stone market
and the application before you is um
the construction of eight solar
pv
carport arrays that is solar panels
above car ports and it includes
the relating battery storage and
five electric vehicle charging points as
well
so to the presentation
and for dividends about the location of
stone market within in the district
the approximate location of the site
within the town
a wider aerial view
the approximate location within the
wider site area
and this is the constraints uh
map the uh site is outlined in
red this thin red line here
um incorporates a large portion of the
car park
there's a little bit more of the car
parked to the south here which isn't
included
um
the site is within the entirely within
the settlement boundary of the town
uh it affects the setting of the grade
two listed building which is over here
at chilton court
it is a public car park
and
it affects the
affects the setting of a public
right-of-way which runs between grains
gainsborough road
and up here past the pastor primary
school
although not a formal
public right-of-way although it is a
paved footpath
to note
there are schools in proximity the
secondary school
to the south and primary school to the
north and
relating fields and of course the ledger
center
and the green circles you can see on the
screen are tree preservation orders
although not directly impacted by the
proposal site
so this is the site location plan
submitted with
the application
and the proposal layout in totality
so we have the
eight
solar car ports there the uh the five
electric vehicle charging points in
association with five existing parking
bays
and the proposed battery locations are
here
and here as indicated by the applicant
and i've got a
separate slide detailing that as well
and it's just a uh a zoomed in
view of the uh northern
portion of the uh the site
and the eastern portion of the site and
i've flipped this round to get this on
the uh
on the slide and so north is to the uh
to the right of the screen as you can
see there
just to be clear and these are the
proposed elevations of the
of the carports
and the proposed battery locations and
this was submitted
as a late paper by the uh by the
applicant just to be sure
under some photographs this is the
frontage of the of the wider site so
we're approaching from the south here
mid-south ledger center and the site is
the
northern portion of the car park
commencing approximately
here
and this is the general area of
the site in front of the ledger center
sports hall
and
as we go around here is the
public footpath i mentioned
and uh nearest uh residential properties
across the way
you can see those
in the opposite view and this is the
listed building in question here as well
and this is just another view
across the uh frontage of the
ledger center looking back towards the
uh secondary school
in this location
now you'll notice in your um
in your papers there is
an um of concern raised by environmental
protection in terms of uh noise created
by the inverters and fans in association
with the uh
equipment um
however that's um can
it's considered it can be dealt with by
way of condition and uh
we have three conditions
uh proposed by environmental protection
um requiring details of
the plant
acoustic specification and noise
assessment
a limitation on noise levels and
proposed mitigation and also a condition
on maintenance of that equipment so um
yes in the interest of um
neighboring immunity and indeed the
character of the area um noise can have
a impact on the on the character so uh
that is the reason for those uh
conditions
also a condition from uh
candy highways in terms of maintaining
the uh the parking uh providing and it's
not considered that the proposal will
affect parking
existing parking provision but uh just
to make sure that is maintained
and uh
yes that really concludes the
presentation um
uh subject to those conditions officer
recommendation of approval thank you
chair
thank you very much alex do we have any
questions for um
the um case officer please or anybody
counselor milan please
yeah thank you so there's no loss of any
parking spaces at the moment
uh no no no that's not proposed to be
and i was conditioned to ensure that
yeah
please
do it just
we've got a plan part of the development
is the battery storage but i don't have
any dimensions of that either height
width or even kilowatt hours so do we
know whether it's a battery that big or
one the size of this room
we don't have any specific details we
have the general locations of those
storage areas but
we'll receive further details by way of
condition
thanks everybody um for the opportunity
to address the committee uh to speak and
support the application which has been
made by the council's regeneration team
um it is a high priority delivery
project within the um climate action
plan for for the councils
it would cover 72 parking bays there's a
similar scheme um in progress albeit
smaller
for sudbury
and
that has been through planning committee
last week
this is a precedent installation for the
district and nationally
and the objective is it's a pilot
learning project from which we can gain
further
detailed knowledge of the technologies
with this type of installation the
benefits and the costs
it's been supported by four hundred
thousand pounds of uk government getting
building fund capital grant
which is being administered by new la
new anglia lep and that's in addition to
the 350 000 pounds contribution that
mid-suffolk has already endorsed through
uh cabinet
essentially it's a steel frame canopy
with a galvanized finish anchored to the
subsurface by a steel anchor piling
which does minimize the invasive work
and results in no net loss of parking
spaces
it will support asset decarbonisation
and offset energy costs as well as
providing
infrastructure for electric vehicle
charging points the system should last
in excess of 25 years with warranties
for that duration as well so
a high specification system given the
public setting
those safety features have been designed
including tamper-proof containment of
cabling dc cut-off technology and robust
construction
essentially the sk the system can
deliver up to 23.7
of the leisure center's current power
demands
and will save over 1300 tons of carbon
over its
lifetime um
initially five electric vehicle charging
points but with ability to add to those
as demand may need over time
and we have appointed a subject to
planning an indus industry leading
contractor to to to deliver the actual
installation by the march 2022 deadline
um we will
put a project team around them to make
sure the project is delivered to time
quality and funding uh requirements and
we have carried out some engagement with
the near neighbours that have been
affected prior to putting the planning
application in thank you thank you very
much
um do we have any questions for the
applicant or council stringer police
yeah same question asked before do we
know how big physically and how many
kills the batteries are so
the technology for the for the battery
storage and it does include um a
recyclable um sustainable technology
it's in the order of around 20 feet a
container um which would be put around
where the current waste bins are we we
did look at the
see if we can contain it within the
front of the premises we might be able
to get that smaller um unfortunately at
the moment the technology is in short
supply because of global shortages on on
some of the
components but we've got a minimum of a
20 foot containment system which is um
similar to what's been provided at the
hold in suffolk at
e m switch so it's the same provider
same scale
same technology
throw the question for case the world
wars piece
yes you mentioned you've got a similar
installation in ipsuch
the county council have used the the
provider for the battery um for the hold
if switch so it's that same technology
and is that particularly noisy
um it's um
so we're not
the the actual specification um we're
still
um
because we've only just appointed the
contractor um the the actual limits and
the the um assessment will be done um
through the planning condition that's
been proposed by environmental but no i
don't know in detail the um
uh the noise output but the contractor
says it's unlikely to ever get above 30
decibels level so it's not not likely to
be a significant issue but we will
comply with any planning conditions on
the noise assessment to the satisfaction
of the environmental officer
thank you
any further questions at all for mr
carvalho
no thank you very much
comments from the ward members at all
we haven't had any comments received
okay in that case i would open this up
to debate counter stringer please
thank you chair uh
yep a
really good place to put
such a scheme i believe that being a
electric vehicle user i look forward
probably to clear the interest look
forward to some
more charging facilities in suffolk
and certainly harnessing of renewable
energy to achieve some of that is a
really really good idea um
we need to be mindful of two things
about this one is i mean
i understand
the concerns about noise because a
cooling fan can make some noise but i
can't see where we could get any noise
levels from the charging points that
the noise level from a charging point is
never going to be as much as the diesel
car that could be parking in that
parking place so i it
that's not a huge problem i did have a
rice smile at page 416 where it mentions
the batter storage cabinet i thought we
were doing a fish and chip shop for a
minute but uh but not uh
yeah i mean
we desperately need this kind of
technology to move ourselves forward uh
and uh and and and it is the the right
place to put it is where people are
likely to congregate for a while uh and
uh yeah or all perhaps if this scheme's
good we can then put solar panels all
over the roof of the existing ledger
center as well i have no hesitation in
moving approval on this scheme chair
thank you thank you casey stringer do we
have any more comments counselor norris
please
thank you i'm happy to second the
recommendation um i think it's a good
place as councillor stringer has said to
put this sort of array
um and i think we have to keep up with
technology and make provision for the
capacity that's required so i'm happy to
second this
or comments encase the men please just
to say it's very nice to be able to
wholeheartedly approve of an application
thank you
do we have any more comments from any
other members no
well i also totally um support this
application i totally agree with the
comments made by uh country stringer
casey norris and councillor mellon i
think this is definitely the way forward
and the amount of carbon it can be saved
over a period of time is excellent helps
towards our you know climate change
emergency so i will be more than happy
to support this as well
therefore we've had a
proposer and a seconder for this i will
now ask the area planning manager to
relay the proposal on the table before
we go to the vote please over to you mr
peyton g thank you
i have nothing to add other than it has
recommendation
case can i ask the governance officer to
um
thank you chair uh the vote is now in
progress if members please go to the dot
gov app and go to the plus sign in the
top right hand corner the vote will then
on potential subsection
of voting in attendance in a light blue
cover
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and taking into account
councillor gord has left the meeting
that is seven votes for and is unanimous
thank you very much
inspection requests need to be reported
to the committee
an unreceived chair thank you very much
indeed and therefore i close the meeting
at 15 37 and i'd like to thank you all
sorry counselor melon
it's just a question i believe we have a
site visit
uh in the bag somehow for felsham when
is that scheduled for
so um update on that is that we've
received just received back our comments
from the consultation as part of the
risk assessment so we'll be looking to
um convene that or send out stuff in the
next couple of weeks
once we've got a date sorted with the
chair
thank you thank you very much everybody
and say the meeting is now closed at 15
37.
you